wonderful christmas time 3d für die
verspätung aber ich musste noch dinge
tun welche versucht diesen ich hätte
heute was machen und wachs igel und ich
habe versucht meine blocking kamera
anders an so mit zoe gatow zu verbinden
damit ihr das sehen können
er hat nicht funktioniert richtig geil
hey leute na schön hallo ihr kleines
gerichte gerade noch rein ich bin ja
wieder hielt er später dass ihr da seid
ich freue mich wirklich
guck mal hier fertigt instagram und
heute geht um die verlosung heute wollen
wir die verlosung zusammen beenden
machen tun so wir haben eine
weihnachtskarte erstellt ihr habt das
vielleicht in meinem letzten blog
gesehen wenn ihr fleißig zugeschaut habt
wenn nicht dann habt ihr pech gehabt
aber auf jeden fall konntet ihr bis
jetzt oder könnte immer noch auf
instagram und habe ein bild schreiben da
wo ich die weihnachtskarte die ich mit
euch in strömen gemacht habt gepostet
habe da kann jeder unterschreiben und
dann könnt ihr eine weihnachtskarte
gewinn also ich schreibe euch dann an
ihr schickt mir eure adresse
ich schicke euch eine weihnachtskarte so
läuft auch gut dass sie das hier nicht
sehen können weil dann muss die ganzen
adressen nicht ausbleiben oder so aber
wir können die gewinner auslosen
okay ich mache was laut standard das ist
20 sekunden oder gar nicht immer ganz
gut
mein ersten ist auch hier also wird auch
ein kleiner muck bank wenn ihr mich
nicht essen sehen wollte macht eure
augen zu oder ohren bitte lächeln
butterweck arbeiten um ein internet
wirkt aber heute hier ganz 20 sekunden
habt ihr zeit 20 sekunden müsst ihr
pause machen beim chat so sieht's aus ok
es jetzt eingestellt wir denken schon
ich kann mir auch einfach mal eine ganze
noch ich frage mich also ich war heute
bei fisch kommt wenn ihr den nicht kennt
könnt ihr den fischkopp könnt ihr
bestimmen
der hat auch im streaming setup und ich
dachte mir so oh mein gott
also eine richtige kamera als streamer
dort drauf und ich habe halt ich habe
einfach so eine webcam
aber die funktioniert super aber das
bild ist halt nicht so geil wie jetzt
bei einem fisch korb oder oder methode
erklär mir das mit den stäbchen bitte er
ist ein fan fiction spaß ich habe hier
essen einmal das habe ich mir heute bei
rewe geholt ich weiß plastikverpackungen
aber es ist eine ecke das plastik und
hier ist papa da bin ich richtig also
das ist für mich richtig cool und die
macht dann so schälchen das ist jetzt
mit ist ein pokémon mit mango und cookie
und die der name und verschroben oder so
und lachs und reis und das war
irgendwann muss ich mal essen
ich war den ganzen tag geblockt war dann
im büro beim boris und habe mit ihm
gesprochen und ich suche gerade in dem
ich selber ein büro und ja da hab ich
mit fischkopp geredet und irgendwann
haben wir so gesagt moment mal wir
können auch zusammen ein büro wenn ihr
das wollt mann freut es mich also was
macht dieses der weihnachtsmann macht
dieses jahr frei kannst du mich grüßen
heiße des flugzeugs mit knapp naja
superklasse
vanessa mach mal vernünftiges video und
keine stream dinge egal ich mache und
vernünftiges video ab januar wieder
falls sie meine normalen videos vermisst
dann freut mich das sehr doll aber ich
habe jetzt noch blocken es gemacht und
streams mache ich wenn ich es nicht
geschafft habe und ich mag streams und
deswegen kriegst du hier den
mittelstädten habe noch nie so viel
gegessen oder gucci ist aber auch was
für leute also das muss man mögen oder
muss man nicht mögen so ok seid ihr
bereit letztes mal haben wir diese
stream haben wir die haben wir die
karten gemacht wenn ihm ein blogger wie
gesagt geschaut ob dann erkennt ihr die
schon hier sind geraten sich nicht ohne
wird sehen die nicht so kann also haben
wir wie ist das eigentlich wenn ich mich
jetzt vergrössert sich dann so viel
schlechter aus purer die qualität ist
schon echt aus hygiene es doch drauf so
hier
das sind die k also ich find sie
mega-thema sieht noch ein bisschen
besser aus als ich aber ich habe jetzt
auch noch neue karten müssen irgendwas
hat aber die kamera so ein bisschen
schlechter als sonst ist sie heute schon
ich weiß nicht woran es liegt
der stream ist ein 3 1 1 ein video 1 3
und 1 muttern ja es ist wahr ich weiß
nicht warum ich mich so gefreut hat was
ist wenn nicht so das licht richtig auf
volle pulle ballack kennt ihr diese
stelle bei traumschiff surprise wurde
die so völlig überlastet sind
warum ich hätte das nicht warum sich die
kamera nicht mal reifen kann und dann
sagt okay wir mit extrem viel licht muss
ja noch näher ran gehen oder what the
[ __ ]
ja das ist ja das ist das noch ein work
in progress
komisch oder liegt vielleicht am mikro
kann ich das mikro nie tiefer machen so
hab dich doch mal okay das ist zu helfen
soll jetzt müsste es doch eigentlich
gefühl das ist ganz schlimm
fragt man sich weiter nach hinten hey
hallo sieht so aus ich glaube es nicht
ich bin auch gerade hier so durchgedreht
weil ich dieses diese bildschirm
verknüpfung zu meinem zu meiner kamera
nicht hingekriegt haben das wäre so geil
gewesen wenn es funktioniert hätte ich
weiß auch nicht warum ich dachte dass es
funktioniert ich finde sekunde habe ich
dran glauben dachte so ja ich krieg das
hat sicherlich gedacht ja geil hier so
geht es doch nicht so ganz
professor vanessa stream
ja ich kann einfach so kommt machen sie
mal ganz gechillt warum sich immer so
gerade mein pc stelle einfach mal meine
pace hörte mich gut ist dass ein nobel
ja das ist ein opel chef
den habe ich tatsächlich bekommen
von lucia weil ich hatte noch so ein
jahr gesucht und dann nämlich gehört
nobel club dem ein oder anderen wenn ihr
aber mega also ich hatte noch nie so
einen gemütlichen stuhl einfach das sage
ich ganz ehrlich wie es ist vielleicht
was das wird nix mehr mit dem mit dem
licht doch so scheiße kaltes licht
ich kann aber auch ja jetzt bisschen
aber leute so ist das leben das
funktioniert halt auch nicht mal alles
perfekt kann ich mal einer die tafel
schreiben
ich muss hier hinten bleiben ein
bisschen hoch mit meinem stuhl obwohl
das geht nicht mit den tisch ist okay
also migräne gut überstanden ja ich habe
ja eine migräne bekommen
ich weiß mittlerweile schnell wie ich
handeln muss wenn ich eine migräne
bekommen sie treue aus und ich schaffe
das schon immer so ein paar stunden dass
sie wieder weg ist es halt auch scheiße
aber das ist alles was ich weiß ich war
eine migräne kommen kann wenn wand also
und sagt der mann sie kommt dann immer
zur falschen zeit aber wann ist man denn
mal motiviert und sagt ja jetzt jetzt so
eine migräne da passt schön war schon
gefreut als sie doch alles heraus was
mache ich hier eigentlich
guck mal das ist doch okay dafür bezahlt
dass jetzt gerade hübsch würde ich jetzt
nicht so sagen aber er muss ich glaube
ich hab mal nicht so ganz nah rangehen
so zum beispiel weil irgendwann muss ich
da mal die kamera austricksen dass sie
so sagt josef kuper das ist doch besser
oder sind nah dran aber es ist gut dass
ich doch auf jeden fall nicht so krass
über leuchtet aus vielleicht bauen sich
das licht wartet
hier haben wir jetzt gebaut des licht
geben ist es gut
also ich okay bin ziemlich ist wenn man
es gegen die wand bauen sondern bauen
ist das von der band zurück und dann
kommt zu verteilter und nicht so als so
strahlt aus bei uns vielleicht ein
bisschen über leuchtet es ist trotzdem
aber es geht ok du kannst du auch deine
sony als webcam benutzen dann hast du
auch ein geiles bild ganz ehrlich würde
ich super gerne machen ich hab's auch
schon versucht ich habe meine egal woran
gemacht und so aber ich habe ein problem
mit meinem pc weil der irgendwie nur
eine hdmi funktionieren dann anhand und
dann hab ich den also ich hab gerade
versucht und ich habe ich das getan was
ich konnte was ich kenne aber was ich
weiß
aber ich bräuchte jetzt noch glaube ich
noch so 20 minuten um das so richtig
einrichten zu können um so schritt für
schritt und das team sollte schon
losgehen und dann passiert okay also
karten
ich habe seine gespannt ich hoffe ich
habe so eine wachs siegel scheibe geholt
ich wusste nicht wie viel ich brauche
dann war ich so 30 karten verschicken
ich weiß nicht wie schnell das abbrennt
ja und dann habe ich erstmal fünf geholt
die waren aber auch am steuer
das sage ich euch so und dann habe ich
genug briefumschläge und mein handy habe
ich nicht dabei aber ich gehe ganz kurze
mal zehn minuten pause dann könnt ihr
euch auch noch mal eine stulle schmieren
und so dann geht es los
ja briefumschläge muss ich nicht zeigen
und dann ist der plan des
also jetzt konnten schon ganz genau zu
dann machen wir das hier zu sein sagt
und wachs siegeln es zu beschreiben wir
vielleicht noch den namen drauf des
gewinners ist und dann ist es vor
weihnachten bestimmt noch da hammer
let's go as und dann hab ich noch gold
stifter weil ich glaube timo wird auch
unterschreiben also ich weiß aber nicht
genau ich glaube ich unterschreibe aber
lieber auf der rückseite oder weil ich
hier das würde das bild kaputt machen so
ich hab da nicht mit euch vier stunden
dran gesessen um da jetzt am ende meiner
unterschrift alles zu versauen
deswegen schreibe ich rechts und timo
links ich hoffe team unterschreibt also
ich habe jetzt gesagt dass er
unterschreiben muss weil so viele leute
gesagt haben er soll unterschreiben und
dann ja hab mir gerade hab mir gerade
dein anhalt livestream nachgeschaut und
sehe dass du jetzt schon wieder stream
ist geil dreist und nur in der st
du musst es dir nicht geben gibt ihn
nicht drei stunden waren er sei keiner
sollte sich drei bisschen anders ergeben
seht ihr das dadurch erhält
da nehme ich also muss ich hier bleiben
rückseite ja ihr seid auch für rückseite
gut
man braucht für eine menge briefe glaube
ich nur so 3 was ist jetzt eine menge
können wir das mal definieren
man gewinnt wenn man jetzt kann man noch
auf instagram unter dem foto das wurde
liegt und kommentiert unter dem unter
der karte also ich hab ein foto mit
dieser karte gepostet und da muss man
nur noch schreiben
und jetzt guck ich gleich wer gewonnen
hat also es gibt programme dafür viele
kosten geld ich habe das jetzt aber auch
bei der letzten verlosung gemacht sich
aktualisiere so lange bis ich alle habt
und dann mache ich so also ich bin 20
jahre alt bin ich nicht aber papa papa
papa und dann noch mal 55 zurück denkt
so und irgendwann guckt nicht hin zeigt
mit einem finger und dann ist es
entschieden
ich könnte auch programme benutzt aber
wie gesagt die kosten geld und wer an
bock geld dafür auszugeben
mal ehrlich grüße aus sri lanka wow
grüße nach sri lanka wie spät es gerade
in sri lanka das liegt an den vielen
schwarz das heißt wenn ich nach hinten
noch mehr licht ballmer das könnte sein
ich kann irgendwas auf mein bildschirm
spielen ihr dürft entscheiden wollen wir
das frei wir nehmen das kaminfeuer von
netflix oder sagte ja ja ich will es
auch also bevor ich hier wieder
irgendwas spoiler oder so ich mache das
jetzt dann aber ich mach jetzt mal hier
christmas musik an
dann bin ich ungefähr zehn minuten weg
also pi mal daumen zehn minuten nicht
meins christmas musikern und dann
komm ich mit kaminfeuer und wachs
stimmung zurück
christmas christmas wussten diese geile
lo fi
ich liebe diese eine playlist er her
bz
das laune
oder das kaminfeuer von netflix mit
weihnachtsmusik ja ich will aber über
die musik nicht
[Musik]
wieso nicht direkt ein weihnachtswunder
auf die bildschirme das ist laut
nehmen wir den fernseher
alles klar also wir sehen uns in zehn
minuten wieder
[Musik]
da sind wir wieder zurück zur musik paul
h und mit kaminfeuer kino.to freust du
dich darauf die karten zu unterschreiben
wie ein richtiger instrumental weniger
in holen soll
dann muss die musik zu laut oder was ist
da kann man sich reiben die sogar haie
glaube ich sie freuen sich die freuen
sich einfach auf dich hab' ich bin
dagegen schild dann muss ich ja ich der
entscheidet sich aber immer wieder neu
und weißt du wenn es so wenig licht ist
dann kriselt es halt immer wieder es
kriselt es muss schon viel ich sein ich
weiß aber nicht warum er mich so
ja ich gebe habe hier noch ein paar
einstellungen immer wieder konfigurieren
so das gibt halt noch das aber ich weiß
nicht was ich da ja noch souverän
belichtung ist halt automatisch aber
wenn ich belichtung automatisch aus
stelle dann erwarte ich mir war immer
wenn ich belichtung guck mal dann bin
ich jetzt so waßmann siehst du das im
bild so wenn es am auto mal ja aber nur
wenn es aber nicht automatisch erstellt
ist einfach automatisch ist dann
kompensierung bei wenig licht sehr viel
licht eine mücke im dezember höher mit
dem rot sieht das ja geil aus das stimmt
wirklich steht mir wieder dahin
das besser ausbreiten
die leute haben ist zu schwarzem
hintergrund weißt du du musst einfach so
stehen
ich sage nichts ohne mein manager halt
dein maul vanessa das sagst du dich
sagen ja wir kommen klar okay also
so ok ich seid ja süß zu salzig schmeckt
das gar nicht dass man ja ja und so
zusammen ich kennen uns ja beide nur
zusammen ich glaube der hat gar nicht
mehr zu der junge der ignoriert mich den
ganzen tag weißt du der uns auf youtube
meine fresse tragen im echten leben muss
meine frisur tragen man jetzt haben wir
sogar noch karten anderen fressen drauf
ok team roboter die ganze zeit schnupfen
nudeln mit sauerkraut und dann habe ich
ihm heute schon von sauerkraut besorgte
dann kann sich das gerät kommen
ich bin nämlich eine gute freundin wir
werden noch so ein richtiges influenza
will aber kapelle drin
ok also jetzt hab ich mein handy
vergessen
ich bin gleich wieder da wo du bist
jetzt mit den leuten alleine
der studie
hallo hab gedacht ich keinen sinn machen
ok franz der guten unterhaltung so okay
jetzt schaue ich bei instagram mal nach
wie viele leute denn da so teilgenommen
haben an dieser verlosung hat man sich
nach bush so ok komisch ich dass du gar
nicht so mache da bleibt man er hat das
ja gar nicht so gut
na gut okay alles klar hier ich bin auf
instagram ich mach du mal zur kasse auf
leute die ist man wenn man schnupfen hat
sie sind gut gegen schnupfen die
schnupfen oder schupfnudeln so jetzt
erstmal auf dienstag haben damit ihr das
aussehen könnten wir das alle zusammen
vielleicht kann ich das sogar in scrum
schaut mal sah
und dann musste ich irgendwas ich habe
es wieder vergessen irgendwie nämlich
entweder schließt sich alles auf
irgendwas konnte ich doch drücken dass
es dann die handy version oder so kommt
aber kommt heute aus scheiße also jetzt
seht ihr das handy auch mein passwort
und so schön sehen dann ihr seht es gar
nicht sorry so da ist es dieses ja geil
so ok 24.000 da kann ich das
wahrscheinlich
ja geil jetzt kann ich die ganzen
aktualisieren mehr interessantesten
stream ich brauche dich mal hingucken
guckt man das blind ich muss trainer
scrollen 123 123
ich könnte oben anfallen und immer so
schon mal zufällig jemanden aussuchen
weil dann haben auch die leute die ganz
oben sind mehr chance was denn ach nee
der sortiert ja es der sortiert hier wie
er möchte das ist ja gar nicht nach 23
schon 23 stunden 23 oder sortiert danach
zeit sortiert doch noch zeit
okay dass viele kommentare was denn
wolltest du das feuer im hintergrund
geht richtig ab
das birken feuer was gibt es einen
auslöser tool muss man dafür nicht geld
zahlen ich meine wenn es so für einmal
kann ich auch gerne fünf euro oder so
dazu führt sein aber comment pickup
punkt com kommentar
ja das sieht so aus wie so ein
instrument so preflop in wasilla
instagram account da ist es nicht machen
ja
aber er auf jeden fall keiner da müsste
ich halt nicht irgendwie so random
komisch ok also leute jetzt gucken wir
mal instagram login
das ist doch die richtige kopieren
einfügen am mount auf juni kommentar s
da sind noch fitter typ lag etwa 142
mehr kommentare als 142 muss ich alle
akteure dieses alle
ich weiß er wahrscheinlich muss ich
jetzt erstmal alle alle laden
ok ich lade jetzt mal alle kommentare
das ist ja wohl absolut
das sind dinge die man vorbereitet bevor
man stream leute ja es ist bleibt
spannend hier auf jeden fall ihr könnt
man nebenbei andere dinge machen
naja ich habe jetzt war jetzt guck ich
das mal neu hat noch mal neu den link
rein aber das ändert ja nichts
aber warum am mount auf kommentars 142
ist ja nicht richtig random winner
so ok also wir haben hier schon mal den
ersten kommentar dass nur von 142,1 aber
was mal da sind 3539 comments was ist
wenn ich hier einfach mal die ual link
kopieren und dann schicke ich ihn dir
mal bei habe ich noch pc
[Musik]
das alles ist alles so link kopieren und
dann gebe ich den mal hier 1 542 what
the [ __ ] war gut
dann hat er jetzt einfach dann nehmen
wir das ist einfach so dann hat 142
comments rausgesucht
oder was sagt ihr das ist das fair
ich habe mir stehen auch fast 4300 aber
er hat ja quasi jetzt schon ja 142
herausgefiltert und aus denen kann ich
ja jetzt dann ist er sich meine ich
glaube jetzt nämlich nicht dass er auch
eine andere seite davon gibt es noch
mega viele der funktioniert sicher eine
besser na gut ich gucken ob ich noch mal
noch ein kleiner da könnt ihr sehen die
kleine jubeln
diese social media dinge die man einmal
ganz kurz draußen wir doch endlich sehen
etwa wanne bleibt
comment pk instagram das problem ist
dass sie glaube ich kosten unfair findet
ihr und nicht fair nicht wer ok als
kleinster name stand da gerade scroll du
immer durch die kommission dann einfach
aktualisieren
das wäre unfair okay okay also für
business schools
filtert und comedypreis eine dunkle kate
ist ok man kann ja auch öfter auf
menschen
vielleicht darin jetzt schon mit
facebook ich muss das ganz gut wieder
zur seite nämlich dass hier irgendwas
liquor stores and africa
facebook-account der des connected ute
instagram trader count 1 pages ich mich
jetzt mal
ja ja ja nein weiter
ex-profi instagram bekannt
okay so ich hab's nicht verbunden ja
aber jetzt muss ich doch
man ist also es gibt noch mal einen
instagram instagram comment picker es
ist ja jetzt kann doch nicht sein dass
die eine aber es hat sich schon bei dem
letzten instagram soll ich schon bei dem
letzten mal das problem youtube
funktioniert mega da hab ich einfach
irgendwo in der url eingeben und dann
hat er mir davon was ausgespuckt aber
für instagram ist es irgendwie ja habe
ich bei den 10.000 kommentar nicht
wirklich da 20 minuten gesessen und alle
kommentare eine wahnsinnige box wiener
pickel in herzen kommend entlang pickles
winners wie soll man mit facebook
einloggen
[Musik]
facebook heute weiter hält folgendes ja
da muss ich ja alles scheiße mein tv
brennt okay ich hab mich jetzt mit the
box verbunden so dass einige jetzt da
dieser features you'll need to talk
about ihr business connect to be able to
install mensch facebook page
aber ich will doch nicht facebook ich
will instagram rising mann ist kost doch
alles ich darf jetzt wahrscheinlich so
50 verbände jetzt alle meinen dank und
klaus mit irgendwelchen
[Musik]
diese gibt es da keiner der doch was
umsonst gemacht hat alle wollen sie ihr
geld verdienen wie kann das sein
kannst du lauter sprechen bitte ja ich
kann lauter sprechen sorry immer wenn
ich nachdenke dann connect nahm das
obwohl in das sap der tod und das obwohl
das der jugend ok 30 stück oh mein gott
ja 30 gewinner haben wir haben terms of
pop ich zeig euch mal was ich mache
30 gewinner terms of pop live com and
select the photo weihnachtschaos im
livestream so und menschen no end
jarvis was muss ich denn hier so viel
muss man zahlen 69 dollar im jahr damit
man gewinner rausholen kann aus
kommentaren what the [ __ ] hurra hurra
one of persia hier dass das ist doch
geil was heißen pedro nicht so 430 ja ja
aber wenn ich 30 leute auf haussuche der
macht mir das jetzt nicht die 30 x 4
dollar
ich esse ich übrigens ein paar
kabelsalat neckar
das kann ich nicht mit paypal bezahlen
mit einer kreditkarte
jetzt muss ich weiter ist ja auch vier
dollar geht schon klar schon so viel für
diese weihnachten ausgegeben geht oder
sind da nicht so schlimm sieht einfach
aus und haben das gras fressen würde
es gibt auch ach so ja mit den like sagt
ihr gerade auch weil man dass da auch
aussuchen kann
kann ich dann doppelt aussuchen das ist
jetzt die frage kommen dann aber ich
glaube man kann nur eins aussuchen ich
glaube man muss entweder kommend viel
action leike foto ach so aber es haben
ja aber ich kann ja nicht leichte foto
mit als filter also ich kann nur ein
filter einsetzen weil so doch
kommend und like
aber es ist die frage jetzt wird er
wahrscheinlich ja jetzt wird er doch
wahrscheinlich 30 gewinnern aus den
kommentaren und 30 gewinnern aus den
lecks rausholen nein mein gott ist zu
mir so leid ich bin so dumm ich manchmal
also zahl auf jeden fall die 4 dollar
bald hier kann ich kompost the terms of
the vision bleak entkommt ein multi 07
actions jetzt auch noch dieser herr
steinacker und ab und er muss mir ja
dann drang gewinners so und ich sag
jetzt auch er muss timo folgen okay dann
muss ich jetzt mal ganz groß meine
kreditkarte holen hammer
es wird jetzt richtig tricky ich muss
auf jeden fall beides erst mal
ausstellen so lange ich das eingeben und
so weil ihr dürft weder meine fresse
wieder meine fresse dabei sehen noch
dieses ding wo ich das eingeben kann
also okay jetzt seht ihr nichts mehr
jetzt kann ich in ruhe eingeben
so war das sind die vielen helfenden
nummer liegen würde
asl
oh jetzt falsch so ok continue
congratulations
petzinka von instagram 4300
das habe ich dass sie mich erst anhören
müssen
also ich glaube es war ein fehler dieses
foto viermal wandel noch mit 1 zu geben
weil jetzt muss er 200.000 accounts
durchgehen und so hätte er einfach nur
diese 4000 kommentare und 24.000 likes
durchgehen müssen
seht ihr jetzt irgendwo irgendwelche
dings nähe
das könnte jetzt sehen naja das könnt
ihr sie hinterher ist nichts so bätzing
303 kann man irgendwie noch mal
[Musik]
ja okay gut wir können an der zeit in
der wir die congratulations leute hier
schon mal raus fildern ist vera komisch
das ist ja die you can't combine und
wenn man dann halt das bildlich geleitet
und kommentiert hat
dann würde er ja niemals jetzt jemanden
raussuchen der mir einfach nur folgt zu
ende
es kann ja nicht sein nehmen ach quatsch
ohne deine cv und einer kreditkarte ist
eine reine nummer you say okay jetzt
kann ich es sehen was man so sehen
du kannst nix sehen wenn man auf mich
hier zu verunsichern
ja also dann bis morgen ja ich werde
hier nur um gewürze oder sie warten muss
man nicht leute was glaubt ihr dass ich
euch jetzt nicht entern kann aber sowas
von werde ich euch jetzt entertainer wir
müssen ja schon mal wir brauchen daher
nur die adressen und die können wir als
allerletztes draufschreiben also das ja
wird ein bisschen dauern
dann bin ich ehrlich mit ruhig
ok also hier sind jetzt die karten und
ich muss hier unterschreiben was ist das
für ein pilot super color permanent type
irgendein der kann wahrscheinlich wenig
gutschreiben und deren nicht sogar
versuchen aber ich glaube das nicht so
gut wie nie über den krassen dennoch
extra ein geparktes alter ich hätte
dieses blöde formal war nicht mit rein
nehmen sollen als ob die leute mir nicht
folgen wenn sie damit gemacht haben
ich bin gerade richtig richtig
enttäuschungen selbst kann ich nochmal
zurück ich versuche mal rückgängig zu
machen
kann man das so schlägt zurück zurück
zurück
wer noch eingeladen
hey ich bin eingeladen ist wollen nicht
ewig dauern
ja die adresse
die haben kann ich auf dieser hätte
zurück comcom
[Musik]
terry
die glocken wir auch nicht auch manchmal
seiten dämlich okay so jetzt habe ich
wahrscheinlich einfach 4 dollar auf
verschwendet das ist aber okay okay
select winner 30 stück selection leike
foto und kommentier foto das mit dem
verlor als ob die medien folgen winners
so dass da unten richtig gut gemacht
waren es vier tonnen sand gesetzt jetzt
meine krieg hatte schon gelegt bestimmt
am sorry
so konnte und dass jetzt wieder so lange
dauert dann werde ich richtig mit ok
troim winners so männer im jeder jetzt
wieder 3000 leute 300.000 leute
irgendwie vorschlagen will bätzing data
vom instagram so ich unterschreibe
diesmal die erste kerze mit komfort
ausgelegt so ok trommelwirbel hier 24
das ist geholt jetzt hat er nämlich nur
die likes und die comments oder sind nur
24.000 accounts hierdurch gehen muss
coco inzwischen bei 1000 ja hammer gut
dass ich das gehört habe hat mich zwar
vier dollar gekostet aber sonst hätten
wir noch bis morgen gesessen so ich muss
jetzt immer rechts unterschreiben und
timo links die muss ich schon aufgeregt
wegen den ersten autogramme zu geben
musst wenn du diesen stift immer so
runter drücken
und irgendwie nichts kommt und dann
kommt irgendwann so ein richtig dicker
schal an farbe
jetzt aber komplett gespalten ok
schreib ich mal wanne oder vanessa drauf
ist ein bisschen persönlicher es eher so
ein formal wann ist mein weg
wenn ich team oder händen kann ja auch
schon das schreiben lassen
mit dem anderen stift vielleicht ja der
stadt auch timo kann zwischen 15 karten
unterschreiben nicht unterschreibt hier
15 karten sowie gewinner wären die
gewinner werden die gewinner werden die
gewinner werden die gewinner
and the winner is a das foto schon mal
nicht hier sind unsere 30 gewinner
ja es hat viel dollar gekostet
ja die muss jetzt alle bei instagram
suchen weil ich kann nicht auf den
account klicken
[Musik]
könnt ihr euch mal sehen war kommt mir
leute da sind die gewinner dank gesät
ihr euch irgendwo ich kann es mal hört
sie könnten ja
die haben wir unser 30 gewinner war so
geil wenn jetzt so ein familienmitglied
von uns dabei wäre okay du kriegst eine
karte also du musst jetzt du machst das
schon wieder du drückst so hat kannst du
kannst du 14 kann unterschreiben also
und dann nochmal 15 weil wir für 30
dass wir so eine schöne unterschrift ist
unglaublich unterschreibt sie jetzt
wahrscheinlich auch sowie von seinem
drittklässler die hälfte kannst du schon
mal mit den hier
aber immer auf die linke seite immer auf
dafür war das dein gesicht meinte ist
nämlich auf der team mitglieder ist sie
mit dabei was ich keine gefreut
oh mann jetzt erwartet dass die leute in
tobenden jubel ausrasten
wie hier im klub lada
nicht wenn du frisch unterschrieben hast
ja nee dann machen sie ja also dann
verschmiert du dir näher bekannte sie
doch so übereinander legen aber so nur
dass der red star
fangen wir mal an die leute an zu
schreiben
keiner keiner raste geradeaus weil er
sich freut
das ist ja super dass sie es trifft
immer die falschen dazu sagt mir ist der
einfall verschmiert ich habe aber auch
schon blühen jetzt einen viel zu
intensiven ja das glaube ich
faber castell alter beste qualität
unterschreibt echte karten
das ist richtig premium schritt den man
hier kriegt
hast du ne geile und das ist schon mal
eine geile die ist richtig cool
hey du bist echt ein geborener influenza
junge wie locker von der hand
du hast den coolen stiftet den scheiß
steht faber castell
also meines ausstehen aber ich wollte
eigentlich den usa ja doch mal das ich
das so ne mit deiner ist golden boy
altenburg scheiße top meinen überhaupt
so richtig trocknet muss leute hier
kriegt er die premium unterschriften
aber vom allerfeinsten so meine sind
fertig kannst du jetzt sich hinsetzen um
die unterschreiben also dann
unterschreibe ich aber auch deine mit
der gleich mit dem zeichenstift und
sitzt du dich erzählen und schreibst die
mit dem ja dann sitzt du hier und
quatschen mit leuten kann also muss hier
die so gut eine unterschrift ich machen
kann ich manchmal nur motto na klar
meister für die leute hier gerne was los
man muss für sich selbst einmal war
nicht immer muss irgendwann lernen
leichtbauhalle hombroich kopfhörer ich
hätte auch gar nichts oder
das war wohl die fahrstuhlmusik okay
let's go to business
ich bin gebt mir richtig mühe
ich habe meiner unterschrift gefeilt der
stift den durch irgend so ein bisschen
dünner
ich muss aufpassen dass ich nicht wieder
irgendwas zwischen die unterschriften
ruhig und so riesig mein kopf ist sogar
eingeschritten hier
ich habe mal wieder nicht gewonnen wie
immer stücke sind alle gewinner die
anscheinend nicht hier
life is pain hallo leute
die zimmer die unterschriften hier raus
leute wie viele gewinner hast du
eigentlich das gesamt ausgelost besser
timo geboren austrian man sieht sein
gesicht nicht aber ich so groß bin leute
es ist ja hier auch vanessa angepasst
dies ein zwerg im vergleich zu mir
wieder ungefähr ich bin 1 95 heute habe
ich nur unterschreiben wenn ich kann
nicht gleichzeitig reden und schreiben
leute es ist zu heftig du hast ja sehr
viel gegessen
verrückte professor wird jetzt passiert
da nichts drin
klein dick gemacht
ja ich habe mich fragt leute ich das
herz versagt aber im tipi selber gemacht
[Musik]
das trocknen oder ja ja ja
wir trocknen die stift überhaupt
timo keine sorgen wegen seiner
unterschrift immer wenn ich die
klassenarbeiten für meinen sohn und
david richards weg immer wieder
klassenarbeiten verewigen so
unterschreiben haben die frage von den
lernen so die unterschrieben hat auch
gott 199 192
was für ein gewinnspiel überhaupt ist ja
mega super super kassel gewinnen diese
weihnachtskarte java com mit mit siegel
das ist schon premium shit ich frage
mich jetzt nur wie lange die scheidung
zum trocknen braucht die ware habe die
war die heiße unterschrieben werden das
ist ja nicht so eine autogrammkarte ist
ja eher wie so ein weihnachtsgruß
jetzt ist getrocknet ein stattlicher
beide gekommen ich habe nichts damit zu
tun gab nichts was mache ich denn das
ist nicht die einzige beide gekauft und
ganzen nichts dafür
es waren nur zufall dass du diesen stück
gekriegt
das sind meine stimme beide premier
wahres alter wo ich hab auch deswegen
eigentlich habe ich ein bisschen wochen
schreiben
das ist nicht deine sagt mit meinem
besitz gehört ja kann man dauerhaft
technischen oder nochmal ein lappen
zwischen die 1
christmas charlie kann man es nicht
wegwischen einfach nur so ganz ja okay
ist das eine arbeit so wenig ist diese
unterschrift wert schalter gut dass ich
komm du hast dich gestern gefragt warum
er nicht da die ganzen baskenlandes rum
weil ich genau das gedacht habe dass
dieser eine stifter leicht auf so
glattem zeug nicht funktioniert und dann
ja was drauf bekommt man das hatte
rechtsetzung glück weide geholt
sorry dass ich mich gerade auf regeln
seine arbeit
das werde ich mal so bhs zins bei einer
verlosung alles nur reis stress ja krass
dass man die wirklich alles einfach
wieder erwischen konnte mai war dein
buch ist wirklich gern meine fans lieben
auch das buch ich freue mich jedes mal
so wenn ich leute mir was zum buch
schreiben
auch immer noch ich habe jetzt vergessen
ich hätte eigentlich also das heißt
vergessen ich hätte jetzt winter
weihnachtszeit hätte ich jetzt echt mehr
werbung wieder für mein buch machen
sollen aber ich denke halt nicht so
verkaufs strategisch so ich denke mir so
wenn die leute das sich holen möchten
dann sollen sie sich das holen und froh
darüber freuen
aber die sollen sich jetzt nicht so
geprellt fühlen mein buch zu kaufen weil
ich in jeder zweiten story sagt also
wenn die echte fans seid wenn ihr zug
richtige feld seid dann holt euch jetzt
mein buch ansonsten glaube ich euch das
nicht dass ihr fans seid
pius stift es einfach besser es ist
nicht die wurststücke es ist einfach
jetzt kann die auch schon damit an
ich habe beide besorgt gewesen
mein schiff wieder haben muss gleich
hier noch mal unterschreiben
mit einem stift guck mal ein bisschen
live streaming und schon sehen wie wir
wirklich zusammen sind wir dauerhaft
doch nun nerven geht so ich es ist kurz
vor meinem also leute
börsig schenkt dem zu weihnachten
einfach so eine packung voll mit stiften
was ist auf der rückseite von den karten
dasteht wie er es wir sehen euch ein
equipment das jahr 2020 voller glück und
gesundheit dann noch vanessa und timo
und eine krone
probier's mal muss stößt es echt gut ach
ich liebe es ein casting
wie kräftig das feuer im hintergrund
aussieht
ich müsste noch so camille saint saens
zu unterlegen so voll
er würde also der hat ja alle
halt mal hier
er vermisst meinem opa ich kann wieder
welche machen es trifft sich gut gerade
[Musik]
mit kunst zusammen unterschreiben so
super star
ach so ich muss unterschreiben und dann
kriegst du die karten und dann
unterschreibst du weißt du musst auch
gleich jungs nie wann dieses kaminfeuer
klingt aber eher wie so ein kochender
capel
ich liebe es zu den geräuschen von
waldbränden einzuschlafen
wenn ihr bock habt schreibt man den
leuchten in der liste und sagt man die
sollen adresse schicken
kann man nicht lesen
sorry du kannst sie nicht lesen auf dem
handy oder den computer auf dem computer
hat das ist ja was scheiße du
kwh machen das ist denke ich könnte
reagiert nicht
man kann die echt nicht sehen
keine ahnung wenn ich ehrlich mit euch
wie man die größe entdeckt wie macht man
ein plus
so
nein
kann die liste com lesen ich schlafe
auch gut bei den geräuschen verhindern
habe wegen seiner ruhe
kann die nicht lesen heben schreiben
ganz slg und scrollen
[Gelächter]
ja ja aber jetzt die frau g
der nachbar oder jemand hat uns besser
bestellt
ja bitte schön wenn ich scrollen kann
nicht halt also dass ich mein so gleich
unterschreiben
war nachbar ja
das springt richtig war muss jetzt
büromöbel suchen für mein neues büro
eine kaffeemaschine und ich mir in
meinem büro ja wohl eher in meinem büro
kaffeetrinken werde da sich hier schön
alleine so entertainer timo grüßen
dresden alles bleibe die gewinne auf
geht's togo am besten ist franke
gewonnen hat ihr fernseher brecht
jetzt wird mir schwindelig ich glaube es
ist noch eine zu wichtig zertifikaten 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 12 13 14 hab ich du
musst es 16 haben
und 110 garten da ist dieser wald haben
mich fertiggemacht
ok keyboard lecker und ist echt so
lecker dass am anfang komisch ist das so
man gut drin ist
hast du durchgezählt ich glaube wir
müssen noch eine unterschreiben
und
14 bis 23
ja ich habe 14 16 das heißt wir müssen
auch kannst du dem schiff gezogen
wir müssen auch hier unterscheiden ich
weiß was ich gemacht habe ich komisch
abgezählt war nicht ganz herr meiner
sinne ja und sonst so
[Musik]
es ist die erste verlosung auf instagram
die christa gemacht wurde so dalli
verlost airports ich fahr los so
weihnachtspost willst du dein stift
haben getrocknete nudeln
die hat ihn die leute möchten dass du
auch anfängt stream kann es bei der
richtigen vorstellen was würdest du tun
wenn du stream würde streamen würde in
den gaming eigentlich nicht so wie du
einfach so recht zu klappen
das eigentlich so ein hörbuch oder so
machen sich auch das war die perfekte
erzählstimme hat um allzu großen
projekte professor gucken wenn er aber
ja
berlin die steckdose gefasst du daheim
aber mit nassen hinten
ich schaue gerade einer person sowie
eine selbst erstellte weihnachts gerade
eine halbe stunde lang unterschreibt und
dabei ist läuft das die weihnachtszeit
leute das ist die weihnachtszeit darum
geht es in der weihnachtszeit andere
menschen zu stocken was man beruflich
ach so na also erst solche sollen
verraten
kameramann und cutter ist ja im stream
haben alle gesagt seine haare sind
abgeschnitten
[Musik]
wer vorher irgendwelche leute werden so
eine karte sind und denken das ist
wirklich aus einer mitteilung wenn sie
fotos aus seiner jetzigen zeit
füreinander mehr in sie total verwirrt
sein
zeitreisen
jetzt müssen wir die leute anschreiben
man heiratet ihr machst du jetzt den
antrag von 936 zuschauern
okay ich bin bereit in einem stream
[Musik]
ich würde dem streamen gebracht und
packen geschenke
es ist ja ich sage nicht dass ich
entertainment bin wo man sich so darauf
konzentrieren sagt um da passiert jetzt
will ich bin dieser diese ihre person
die mit ihrem raum ist so nebenbei die
irgendwas erzählt die jetzt einfach mal
aber ich hasse weil du dich nicht mal
anlegen weil du legst einen gewichteten
dann sitzen wir hier so wird so hinten
[Gelächter]
naja jetzt muss ich die leute weil man
jetzt müssen wir mal die leute an
schreiben aber bitte nicht die leute zu
sperren das wäre unfair ja der erste
account hat es ja schon mal mega geil
hier die krisen zahlenkombinationen
ich hab sie tatsächlich gefunden
ich kann hier nicht schreiben weil ihr
konto privates leute was machen wir mit
privaten dann kann uns kann man mal hier
bei dieser sitzung ist alle gemeinsam
entscheiden und weiß es nicht
um seine person erreichen jetzt muss
sich der person folgen oder was muss ich
einfach angefragt nächste person sind
das für namen jugend da bist du ist auch
privat man sie auch folgen habt eure
sachen privatleute die uns nicht alle
besser sein und hier in vielen modellen
iq modi nico nabu
was soll ich treiben den gewinnern
adresse her du hast gewonnen ja ich habe
adresse her du hast gewonnen
[Musik]
können sie mir war gleich mal kopieren
du wirst live im stream jetzt habe ich
nicht kopiert kopieren haben wir noch
bürger ist das eine arbeit ich glaub's
nicht unterstrich 28 da bist du
nachricht keiner von ihnen hat sich
schon bei mir gemeldet keiner checkt
keiner diesen stream gewinnen und ihr
alle leidet weist oder kleine mann der
muss wieder leiden kopieren
der who
[Musik]
so fahren hier diese so adresse her du
hast geworden er gibt immer deine
adresse groß geworden alter kriegs
weihnachtspost vor mir bist du
china mit baby ja leute manchmal noch
mal probieren jetzt mal so im
hintergrund
du kannst auch privaten beiden schreiben
in dem durch die drei punkte im profil
auswärts und treiben so mein gott ist
das schon okay wir machen jetzt das
maximum
alle die wirklich committed sind und
sich drei schon mal beim essen und
schreiben daran sie kriegen mal wieder
nicht gerade mein date machte gerade
meinen tag habe es ist doch so ganz
ehrlich ich hätte am liebsten hier unter
den zuschauern des streams normal bei
ihr seid wirklich treue visa aber so ist
das karmann gibt es nicht wenn du auch
scheiße bis gute sachen das feuer wieder
einmal ganz kurz den kamin wieder an
so dem fernsehen nämlich ihnen mit ins
neue büro timo sage ich dir jetzt schon
mal im fernsehen nämlich mit ins neue
büro wachs igel oder ich bin wieder voll
abgelenkt von dem essen
ich habe gewonnen geschrieben
danke für das gute appetit machen wir
nicht weil alles mit ins neue büro zeige
sich den kühlschrank
ich glaube ich würde mich umbringen wenn
ich den koffer mitnehmen würde
er wird mich nehmen
nix gut vorher so in meinem livestream
wechseln wir uns heute wachsen
okay die blogging kamera an damit ich
scheiße aber ich freue mich wenn ich in
dieses neue büro gehe da habe ich da
leute die gut stream können und dann
können sie mir ganz viel beim streaming
beim für streaming beibringen dann kann
ich mal so richtig geil streamen wie so
eine anni bedanken nicht so schwierig
dass er dann sagen machen
wie läuft eigentlich mein leben zurzeit
ist eine gute frage
eigentlich schön also ich bin ja mal
echt fan von der weihnachtszeit ich
liebte ich find auch zur winter
depression und so nicht schlimm ich
finde nämlich dass so eine
winterdepression er so eine zeit wo man
sicherheit wo man halt wieder
runterkommt weil man also klar kann man
irgendwo wo es immer warmes und es kann
halt immer party und halligalli sein
aber eigentlich braucht unser kopf auch
mal so eine zeit wo wir deprimierter
sind bedingt weil dann fühlt sich die
freude dann wenn es wieder wärmer wird
und fühlt sich freut einfach viel lila
an und man genießt es vielmehr wenn
immer dein leben auf so ein hoch ist
dann fühlt er sich ja irgendwie nicht
mehr nach hoch an und ich glaube wenn du
dann mal eine schlechte phase hast das
ist so ein bisschen wie im winter
trainiert einfach dein körper
traurigkeit
versteht ihr was ich meine weisheiten
mit vanessa wann ist er beschwert sich
die ganze zeit aber liebt ihren job
ich hab schon okay also neue musik
runter ihr irgendwie komisch
ganz ehrlich ich habe ja auf dem kopf
heraus nur die musik gehört aber es
fühlt sich so komisch an wenn ich nicht
die musik drauf waren
wisst ihr was jetzt richtig asozial wäre
wenn ich die ganzen adressen von den
gewinnern liegen würde weil ich gerade
daran denken würde weil ich dachte das
ist das werk so wir machen jetzt eine
karte rein
und ich stecke da ist es gut dass ich
ein siegel drauf machen muss man sich
schnecken und siegeln kennt ihr das also
braucht man ja und dann und dann das
siegel drauf oder segelt man es einfach
nur zu und das ist dann das nicht aber
ich habe mich nicht so vertrauen auf
dieses siegel dass er so denkt oh
nachher kriegt ein bisschen dna von mir
mit pervers dass man das so mittel und
zu machen
ich wurde im falschen land ich bin voll
der winter fan aber gerade haben wir
hier kurze hose wetten dass ja das
stimmt schon ich wollte jetzt auch
einfach mal über weihnachten mal nach
norwegen oder so damit man einfach
dieses winter kalt kamin der
weihnachtsmann kommt so und wir es
wieder weihnachten und es wird wieder
wärmer jeden tag kannst du den berliner
akzent
ich sag mal so ne war ich kann gar kein
akzent außer meinen eigenen den
hamburger den ich weise zeit ein
bisschen weg drücke merklich weil so
weit über meine beste freundin aus kiel
hier ist sie kommen für die nur zur tür
rein und wir sind new york sowie worden
jawohl gut ja ein bisschen schlauer aber
kennst ja ne yo yo zu setzen wir uns mal
hin
nur wie zum bier georg ein problem sie
kann brechen lieber noch zu ok dieses
siegel kann brechen sowie unsere
beziehung oder deine karriere lieber
nochmal die suchen ja ich will jetzt das
erste siege machen aber ich brauche
keine geil
deshalb holt es nicht so die
schwierigkeit ich brauche gar nicht die
kopfhörer drauf ist aber irgendwie fühlt
sich das so kalter und kopfhörer
ich lasse sie immer runter habe ich hier
ein bisschen da
so ich habe auch dieses ding hier
gekauft das hat stolze 16 euro 20
gekostet und hat sohn so musste das von
starker player okay also wenn ihr das
von ferne sehen wollt dann guckt morgen
den block weil ich nehme jetzt auf wie
ich das liege mache okay ich weiß ist es
schade und ich weiß was ich meine
ok ach stimmt er warte man liegt und was
meine kreditkarte nehmen ist der beste
stimmt ich habe irgendwie irgendwie habe
ich nicht dran gedacht ja leider jetzt
machen wir mal erwachsen wir reisen die
zeit 1970 gehörte es gibt noch es gibt
jetzt es wird jetzt noch richtige
richtige crazy butter dazugeben mit dem
classic jedoch
das muss aber ich will ja nicht
christmas
modern classic rosendorn nicht will
classic machen wir morgen was ist das
hier
mutter fragt das nicht den hass oder
hier hatte pops motion classic classic
sodann mal ein bisschen klassischer
musik rein so ok alles klar
okay leute jetzt wird das hier aber
jetzt pyrotechnik nimm lieber dein
flambieren ding aus der küche ortsrecht
wo ich bin so aufgeregt
das ok das schmilzt schnell
trainer brief wieso darf man sich heute
jedes polizei masse
das hat mein brief grad verbrannt
[Musik]
zur geisel
ich glaube ich weiß warum jemand gesagt
hat er sich den flambieren nehmen soll
so halten
ich sehe schon dass ich mein leben hier
abbrennen okay das reicht ja
wahrscheinlich
ja das sieht schon ein bisschen nach
harry potter aus wenn ich wenn ihr mich
fragt
vielleicht nehme ich wirklich mein
flambieren
aber ich habe ich keinen bock irgendwas
abzubremsen noch einmal in die kamera
ich will mal ganz kurz den
[Musik]
ich hole mir die premiere
jetzt weißt warum wieder in die
wachstumszone verkauft haben noch viel
geiler ist diese wachs pistole wehrleute
welcome
das ist mein flambieren wir machen mal
noch ein brief eines eine übungssache
hier brief um brief an schlecker
wie macht man das noch mal ich es
vergessen guest auf volle stufen 1
konnten es konnte
für jeden zu kokeln
so und dann ist das live drauf hast dass
eine arbeit als raster aber es ist auch
das gefühl ich meine wohnung abfackelt
damit kann ganz ehrlich ich bin nicht
der typ der flawiler macht ich bin nicht
so ein pyrotechniker ich mein
so also braucht man einfach noch mehr
geduld dafür
[Musik]
es ist nicht einfach das bleigießen zu
machen also ein stück wachs über die
flamme und dann aufs brief schatten ich
hab sogar sohn bleigießen
[Musik]
ja das ist für besser das ist besser
dass es besser ich habe sogar noch so
ein ding von blei gießen
ein moment wir sind gleich wieder für
sie da
[Musik]
ok
ich habe meine equipment da die
operation alter okay ich zu mir jetzt
diese kerze an
welcome to dj channel
yankee candle please ponzoni so jetzt
haben wir diese kerze hab mal hierhin
und jetzt werden wir den teufel
burdisso die macht so einen schwarzen
raucht es geht alles in meine lunge rein
diese katze und wir dies so die macht so
viel schwarz und dies von yankee candle
alter so dass das ding ist von blasen
so
und jetzt werde ich aber immer so ein
stück wachs dazu haben helmut alles klar
also ich schneide jetzt mal einfach so
[Musik]
ab 9 ja bis jetzt fest
was soll ich kenne aber auch wenn wir
meister sind mit diesem wachstuch der da
jetzt so da drin ist
weil sie heraus ziehen ja doch ganz
einfach als gedacht okay so jetzt muss
meinen gerätschaften bereithalten
jetzt halte ich das wachs so über der
kerze und das schmilzt jetzt
funktioniert und mein gott danke für die
idee das ist die beste idee aller zeiten
so funktioniert vorschnell alter
das wahrscheinlich auch viel zu großes
stück kuchen essen
hier mit in die schule für zauberei und
hexerei aufgenommen so hat das magritte
elvis auch zu hause gemacht weil sich im
büro gesessen
geschmolzen
bitte fertig schmelzen
[Musik]
wahrscheinlich zu viel aber jetzt haben
wir es so und jetzt wird darauf geklebt
oh mein gott das funktioniert super oh
mein gott das ist die beste idee aller
zeiten
außer dass der brief recht anbrennt
[Musik]
damit es ein wunderschönes säge leute
ich muss aufpassen sich hier nichts
anbrennen aber guck mal richtig zauberei
und hexerei und ist noch ziemlich
flüssig vielleicht noch auseinander
okay es war definitiv ein großes stück
was aber schön ist das heißt ich brauch
nicht so viel aber richtigen so ja dann
kriegen halt die verkrüppelten anfangs
versuche aber das nicht schön
kriegt im leben hat nicht nur das beste
so jetzt haben wir einen neuen
briefumschlag und eine farce
das sind schlechte schläge machen nimm
ein schwamm zum anfeuchten und das hat
schon vor gut funktioniert eigentlich
ein schwamm zum anfeuchten zum ich hab
ja ich bin doch klappen
rudi de nennt habt ihr alle super ideen
mit ist feucht ok also jetzt hier wieder
so ein stück abschneiden aber diesmal
ein kleineres definitiv kleiner
a
wenn hier die schnur entfernen
monstadt wegziehen
mit dem exil das schön flüssig
es können jetzt hier auch guckst du
musst warten dass es getrocknet ist und
dann erst den stanser abziehen als klar
besser
die flamme
knapp 2 auf gerade so ein bisschen zu
flüssig muss kurz abkühlen lassen in
diesem ding
so jetzt haben wir es müsse
das braucht auch nämlich so dass sich
warten
okay so
ja das ist eine bessere menge glaub ich
ok
und jetzt der stanser drauf
also sagen dass nach unten weg gestanzt
derzeit mache ich jetzt hier um eine
produktion weiter toll all das muss ich
nur 30 mal machen soll ich mir
ausgedacht
ja
schön schön ist dort ja so wie das jetzt
weiter so sieht jetzt mein abend aus
super aber ich glaube ich werde zu den
stream ausmachen weil so spannend ist
das glaube ich nicht wie ich gerade
denke
also ich werde jetzt die ganzen gewinner
anschreiben vielleicht könnt ihr sie
auch in anspruch
vielleicht könnt ihr mir auch die arbeit
abnehmen die ganzen verlierer
ja und dann nochmal da wir noch mal 40
für familie und freunde ist das nicht
geil so wird mein abend heute aussehen
ich wollte noch mal in ich muss noch
bilder malen weil ich dieses jahr bilder
bilder verschenke wird kommt von herzen
schaltet auch beim nächsten stream
wieder ein wenig möbel für mein neues
büro suche
nein das instrument doch das an halo war
das alles gibt dann lasse ich ihn an
timo muss er gleich weg das heißt ich
bin alleine ich meine ja die musik
wieder an leute die war nicht
unterschrieben
ja das kann sein dann hat jemand eine
nicht unterschrieben
ich weiß in stream an
ihr habt recht wollte meine fresse dabei
sehen oder das was ich tue das müssen
die leute jetzt entscheiden ob sie mein
gesicht sehen wollen oder wachsen briefe
ja ich lasse den stream anja leute er
jetzt einmal auf ihr schon gesagt
mega beruhigend das finde ich schön
ich kann auch flüstern presse oder fax
brief die fresse fresse beides beides
bugs uns wachsen briefe gesicht war so
tust was im brief was du tust am besten
beides deine fresse webcam manchmal etwa
gut fresse gesicht komm ich meine ab und
zu wechseln ich auf links ab und zu wenn
länder wie man in unseren chat reinkommt
fresse briefe fresse polieren
die macht die gewinner beck
versucht gerade irgendeine herausfinden
wie ich beide stream können dabei
übersteigt meine vorstellungskraft
ausruhen beide ich habe gerade wirklich
weil mein hirn hat gerade so richtig
gemerkt dass ich wahrscheinlich auch
einfach beides streamen kann die man
fünfmal hier alles frei stellen die
webcam um also wir sehen es einfach ein
fünf minuten wieder extreme nur für euch
weiter leute weil ihm eine weitere seite
seit in meinem herzen manchmal werde ich
auch zu einer sitzenden person
[Musik]
hier ist der geist der vergangenen
weihnacht vanessa geschäft so ok pauli
ist dreckig ist dreckig alter
wie schön
zur seite so und jetzt machen wir mal
vielleicht kriege ich das hin dass ich
das einfach raus summe
wie überhaupt herangezoomt ist die frage
ich hab nicht mehr angesagt wenn so blöd
okay dann muss ich das wieder zurück
machen die scheiße hier dann runter
gehen ein lob ich oh ja jetzt weiß ich
was ich gemacht habe
moment ich hab's zugeschnitten aber wie
schneide ich es wieder
zugeschnitten
davis nicht zugeschnitten ich hab's
fertig gibt es hier eigenschaften
er war bis hin zu geschnitten werden
irgendwo zwischen thema doch ich könnte
geradeso transformieren dhabis zuschnitt
transformieren und so besser ok
ja du stellst du kleine new day
erst einmal mein mikro so abgesprungen
ich sage mir zu viel bewegt habe
ich bin eine gewinnerin heißt daher
schon jetzt freut mich wird das ihr euch
so freut die gewinner freuen sich auch
ganz in rosa bluse habt nicht geworden
ja komm warum der kann jetzt wieder
scharf stellen
hier waren sagt grade oder vielleicht
stelle ich einfach so rennen eine
wasserflasche vor dass sie dazu
ich frage mich nicht was ich hier gerade
versuch ist schade
na ja hast du jetzt richtig aus das wird
schon klappen
ok so willkommen bei dem entspanntesten
stream hier auf youtube
wir machen wieder ein bisschen dreck
so jetzt ist die weihnachtskarte auch
unterschrieben falls ich eben gerade
eine nicht unterschriebene reingemacht
habe i'm sorry
verlierer sind auch für star wars
nein ich mag es dauert leider nicht nass
gemacht
geklappt hat das nicht gereicht oder was
der rastet verlassen hatte er kommt noch
nicht so klar auf die
die gewinn habe ich schon gezeigt die
ich habe noch nicht alle gewinne
angeschrieben
es mache ich gleich im anschluss jetzt
hab ich das schon jetzt kann ich auch
nicht mehr blicken gema bitte einfach zu
naja wie war denn bis jetzt eure
weihnachtszeit wie würdet ihr sie
bewerten von der skala von 1 bis 10 habt
ihr schon weihnachtliche sachen gemacht
wir waren gestern auf dem
weihnachtsmarkt und hat mir wieder
aufgefallen wie unglaublich voll die
weihnachtsmärkte sind aber wir hatten
eine gute tag legt wenn wir zum einen
glühwein geholt und mit dem glühwein
haben wir uns dann eine frist stand
angestellt und dann als wir glühwein
fertig hatten haben wir fressen bekommen
haben uns wieder neue weingut und auch
seine anderen fritz stand gestellt
da hat man die langen schlangen
überleben können was mache ich hier
ich leg dir gleich funktionieren immer
noch am besten
pietsch strip zu kleben verletzungen
hey hallo ein bisschen dna von miercom
ohne dass dieses ganze gewinnspiel noch
wie geil so jetzt kommt wieder unser
krieg hier ein
wann haben wir das crack hier wieder
flüssig gemacht und ich muss alles
bereit halten
habe keinen bock auf weihnachten ich
verstehe nicht warum leute keinen bock
auf weihnachten haben nur fans aber ich
denke mir immer so ist doch sowas gibt
es an weihnachten was man nicht mögen
könnte so etwas bringt bringt dich in
weihnachtsstimmung kehrt das ist doch
super das war auch definitiv mein ziel
aber ich weiß auch nicht wie also
so gut dass craig ist flüssig
klassiker jetzt sein können so michael
mann dann kommt jetzt das siegel drauf
das wird ein perfektes siegel das spüre
ich jetzt schon dass wir perfekt leute
das wird einfach perfekt wo bin ich hier
getestet du bist hier im renaissance
[Musik]
waxing gelandet da ist doch nicht so
perfekt gewesen ich brauche mir sinn
mehr
sieht echt aus als ob ich die harry
potter briefe fertig mache ich bin eine
kleine weihnachtsfee von dumbledore hier
mit der zauberei hexerei schule gemeldet
auch falsch rum oder nicht meine arbeit
ist stressig und an den feiertagen ist
familie stressig
also arbeitsstress ich ja familie
stressig oh ja bin selber muslime feuer
kein weihnachten aber weihnachten
einfach geil die serien filme schnee
leider momentan ja genau weil es geht
also wenn wir wenn wir mal wirklich
ehrlich sind so wer guckt sich denn
heutzutage noch für die kirche so
richtig also ich bin selber noch in der
kirche
ich bin aber jetzt wirklich nicht mehr
kirchlich also ich würde heute getauft
und so
aber weihnachten das eigentliche
christliches fest so aber also ich finds
auch nicht schlimm dass auch
nichtchristen oder wenn man es feiert
ohne dass man den christlichen gedanken
dahinter so weihnachten ist auch einfach
so ich finde dass es wieso hochzeit für
die familie so einfach einen grund um
zusammenzukommen sich zu streiten zu
essen und auch wirklich mal zeit
miteinander zu verbringen ich kenne so
viele familien die ohne weihnachten
wahrscheinlich nie sich zusammensetzen
würden mal einen geburtstag okay aber
weihnachten doch so richtig da haben
alle frei wirklich und nimmt geburtstag
nicht wenn du da feiert dann kommt da
auch nicht wirklich jeder man auch wenn
man seine familie nicht so leiden sich
also so gut versteht oder so kann man
trotzdem also am ende ist doch mal eine
gute gelegenheit sich vielleicht mit
leuten auszusprechen oder mal auch
streitigkeiten beiseite zu lassen
was machst du deine was macht dein
bruder über weihnachten war mein bruder
ist in new york der also books also der
freut sich über weihnachten
ich halte meine familie mein gott ist
das dramatische musik radio voll
erstatten
das kraken geht in die nächste runde
bei uns hat es heute 20 grad das ist das
schöne musik das santiago
ich muss auch an heilig arbeiten
arbeiten wird stressig danach schreiben
fertig machen wir doch so vorbereiten
oh mann ich musste auch so oft an
weihnachten arbeiten früher also ich
habe gearbeitet und habe die regale und
so eingeräumt deswegen weiß ich wie
nervig das ist also an heiligabend
vormittags nicht an weihnachten richtig
so
das sieht so krass aus lobt auch richtig
wer nicht auf den brief mache ich hoffe
dass brennt kein loch dadurch
ob man schon wieder neues das ist mein
brief baten dieser musik wechsel ja der
ist so hart aber das ist einfach in
dieser classical playlisten gewesen ich
weiß ich warum die da so dramatisches
gibt mir nicht um hier also ich schätze
mal dass dieser stream heute bis 22 uhr
gehen wird ich habe es irgendwie im blut
ich mache jetzt mal alle wir müssen mal
hier wir machen das jetzt mal richtig
geordnet okay ich jetzt erstmal alle
briefe an die kamera kommt mal aufs
leben klar und ja
ich muss sich das viel zu dramatisch
ja ich arbeite auch bei rewe hier wird
ein super arbeitgeber wir wollen jetzt
nicht mit mir zusammenarbeiten ich frage
die immer wieder die lust haben mit mir
zusammenzuarbeiten
immer kommt nur ein jojo mehr in uns
bald da nicht
zumindest für bessere karrierechancen
kriegt man immer noch ein höherer
mindestlohn
ja aber es war entspannt ich mach das
es war stressig während der schulzeit
bei rewe zu arbeiten aber wenn du mit 18
schon so ein gehalt krieg so wirst du
nicht auch deine eltern angewiesen
ich habe einen die taschengeld bekommen
deswegen musste ich halt seit ich 14 bin
habe ich regelmäßig gearbeitet
einfach nur um normale sachen machen zu
können dann hat man halt ein haus
gekauft und so und wahrheit kein geld
übrig für spaß
was war dein schönstes erlebnis zur
weihnachtszeit okay das ist eine story
ich habe ein erlebnis was mir echt so im
kopf geblieben ist das war da haben wir
noch in hamburg gewohnt da war ich
glaube ich acht oder so
der ist so perfekt geworden was sie
immer eine kamera nicht sogar sogar guck
mal da kann man das jetzt einfach hält
schon fest ich kann nichts sagen
also da war ich acht und dann ist mein
vater mit uns raus gegangen und wir sind
zu so einem spielplatz um die ecke
gegangen und visa spielplatz hatte so
ein hügel und das war so ein weihnachten
da war das alles komplett vereist und
also ein bisschen schnee lag aber es war
tatsächlich lebt vereist dann irgendwann
sind mein bruder und ich dann diesen
berg runter geschlittert auf unseren
füßen und mein vater hat irgendwann mit
gemacht und wir haben so lange also wir
sind immer wieder hoch und haben es wird
einfach runter geschlittert und ja und
dann sind wir irgendwann nach hause
gekommen
und das war ein heiligabend halt und
werde mir nach hause und dann standen da
meine schwester meine mama hat gerade
den weihnachtsmann verpasst ich weiß
nicht was ich da so richtig enttäuscht
war
aber es war auch gleichzeitig so medical
so mein gott wir haben ihn ganz knapp
verpasst
mist
wenn jetzt jemand die polizei zu rufen
würde dann würde ich aber rede ausrasten
ich weiß nicht ob wohl ganz ehrlich wenn
ich würde einfach sagen ja ich bin's
youtube-stream er gerade es war halt ein
idiot wenn die mit dem swat team rein
kommen dann biete ich dir noch einen
kaffee
könnte eventuell ein wie schmeckt mit
gewitter im kopf machen oder so ja mit
denen würde ich gerne mal drehen ich
habe dir jetzt schon glaube ich drei
oder viermal auf irgendwelche events und
so getroffen habe ich auch mal ganz gut
mit den unterhalten aber ich wollte
jetzt auch nicht zu dieser hype zeit als
also jetzt wo sie halt so bleibt sind
haben natürlich viele bei den
angefragten heute mit dem drehen und so
was ja auch cool ist aber ich hatte
keinen bock da jetzt noch auch mit dabei
zu sein und dann zu sagen hey wollten
auch mit mir drehen
harry potter musik fließt ja kann ich
leider nicht machen
was war deine schwester was ist deine
schwester war die auf meinem video nie
meine schwester hat man noch nie gesehen
um einen großen bruder wir noch einen
großen bruder der in polen wohnt den hat
man auch gesehen
und immer wieder eine folge lang arzt
gemacht ja wir wollten eigentlich wieder
drehen aber es war ihr habt ihr das
video wahrscheinlich mit freddy und
trank drang kitchen gesehen also das hab
ich ja beim swing geschaut falls ihr den
letzten jahr gesehen habe war ich war
einfach zu toren kommen dann noch weiter
zu drehen
wie findest du das mädchen polizisten
werden wollen absolut absolut geil also
unterstütze ich komplett ich habe eine
freundin dieses polizistin geworden was
aus der schulzeit eine freundin hammer
das ist genau weil ich finde immer
frauen sind das schlaue geschlecht und
das braucht die polizei auf jeden fall
mehr mehr bisschen mehr diese weibliche
intuition wirst du was ich meine ich
gerät gar nicht so von intelligenz dass
man das nachmessen kann wie auch das
gefühl immer frauen
wir sind so ein bisschen oder timo
frauen haben eine bessere weibliche
intuition
wer oft ja wir sind ein bisschen wie ein
bisschen mehr wie little finger an der
das kann man schon sagen es sind so
viele briefe
warum habe ich nicht überlegt dass
vielleicht 30 briefe einfach 25 zu viel
sind
wie findest du es wenn mädchen also
leute wenn mädchen anwältin werden
wollen das finde ich absolut aber wenn
mädchen meine nichte will staatsanwältin
werden
und ich sage so johann josef witte es
gibt nichts was man nicht werden kann
wirklich außer wenn du irgendwelche
körperlichen voraussetzungen nicht
erfüllt oder ein wenig zittern der hände
und chirurg werden will ist gut dann
gibt es ein problem aber an sich es gibt
keine geschlechter
jobs so wenn man bis zum kindergärtner
werden willst dann mach das bitte und
denkt nicht daran irgendwelche leute
könnten heute gedanken haben ganze
koreanische restaurants in berlin
empfehlen ja ich war jetzt bei einem und
den könnte ich schon empfehlen ich hab
aber vergessen wieder hieß wo war dieser
ist wo war dieser kurieren barbecue der
wein klecker timo wobei die batterien
barbecue einer schönleinstraße system
hier also an der schönleinstraße gibt es
im kurier auf der bank vor dem fernseher
das ist so geil team und ich haben
insider oder so ein ding bei uns laufen
das egal was er sucht ich weiß wo es
liegt
und manchmal sogar kurz und sagt okay
aber dann kannst du mir ganz gut sagen
was ich suche schon wieder
und dann sage ich halt so das liegt da
und hast du schon alle
weihnachtsgeschenke also leute
weihnachtsgeschenke letzte sie haben wir
von übertrieben was man so kaputt
timo internet eine schneise der
zerstörung
also wir haben jetzt ja wohl übertrieben
und
deswegen will ich dieses jahr für jeden
mich ab leinwände gekauft ich habe neue
farbe geholt und dieses jahr mal ich für
jeden ein bild ob er sich aufhängt oder
nichts ist ihm frei überlassen aber
[Musik]
richtige weihnachtspost geil oder finde
ich auch in maribor sowie dazu muss ich
lernen lief ein lehrling gibt dass er
kleiner weihnachten für briefe nicht
gehört da hat wohl jemand ist was sind
das für briefe ja das frage ich mich
auch gerade eigentlich was ich hier tue
man das für briefe was mit meinem leben
gehört und wie schmeckt der
briefumschlag wie schmeckt ganz gut muss
ich sagen sehr neutral
ich habe das gefühl früher mein gott
dachte gerade recht da ist ein kamin im
hintergrund mails kann kein echter als
im fernsehen
ich würde ich sehr gerne helfen würde
garten danke daher schmeckt
ansonsten sollte man ja stimmt dann
heiligabend werden bis zum 23 machen
ach guck mal wenn ich jetzt mal die
nation besonders annehmen würde dann
könnte schön an der seite hier etwas
steht aber noch zu blöd um sowas
einzustellen und so sehr geht es mir
dann nicht ums geld weil ich einfach ein
toller mensch wenn du ich hab sie
festgelegt ich gerne so hier die
hogwarts briefe sind ready sind es 30
56789 20 21 22 23 24 ein moment
da muss ich richtig tschüss sagen leute
da muss ich noch mal den tisch sagen ja
die gewinner sind bekannt die sind
bekannt
kannst du polnisch sprechen ein oder
andere würde sagen ja aber
also ich kann beim bäcker brötchen
bestellen sowie sag ich
sam
si
28 29 30 euro
das wäre jetzt auch was gewesen wäre
wenn ich da jetzt ein vergessen hatte
namen musste meine oma noch durch die
gegend fahren oder einen applaus für die
bewohner
wer seine oma durch die gegend fährt ist
eine ehren frau die gewinner die ich
habe schon ein paar auf instagram
angeschrieben aber noch nicht alle
ich muss jetzt erstmal hier diese ganzen
dinge du fertig machen und dieses auf
instagram anschreiben das ist wirklich
so boring da kann man halt echt nichts
also dass da könnt ihr halt nur
zuschauen machst du mal ein fantreffen
ja so was wie ein fantreffen macht man
nicht mehr leute das ist wirklich 2000
oder die tig dabei machen es noch weil
die opfer sind ja auch schon relativ
groß
also so ein fantreffen macht man
eigentlich nicht mehr weil man damit
immer die sicherheit der menschen nicht
garantieren kann
wenn du also wenn du irgendwo sags ja
kommt mal alle nach volkskirchen und ich
darf irgendwann platzt triffst und da
jemand was passiert dann bist du schuld
und dann musst du die verantwortung
dafür tragen dass irgendjemand keine
ahnung verquatscht wurde
was steht da drauf habe wirklich keine
ahnung also das sind karten
ich weiß nicht wer allerdings aber das
sind karten die hat da haben leute
gewonnen und jetzt machen wir hier ein
bisschen crack und verschließen die
karten damit manchmal nicht dass es so
auch zwischen voll giftig alter
na komm so schön flüssig werden
vielleicht hat da sicher
sicherheitsabstand der muss
gewährleistet werden
bist du schon in weihnachtsstimmung ich
bin mega an weihnachten will man jetzt
auch mit weihnachtsmusik
das ist hier eher classic dass wir hören
so okay jetzt haben wir flüssiges wachs
und jetzt schaut man was passiert leute
hokus pokus fidibus dreimal schwarzer
kater
die werden immer besser übung macht den
meister leute übung macht den meister
lieblingscharakter aus harry potter um
das schwer
ich bin grad woher wisst ihr ich gebe
euch einen tipp
ich kann euch mehr tipps geben aber ein
gebe ich euch wirklich wenn ihr nicht in
weihnachtsstimmung kommen kaum könnt
dann vergesst diese alten filme und so
wie kann man nur mit weihnachtsstimmung
kommen aber um in weihnachtsstimmung zu
kommen
da hört man sich harry potter als
hörspiel an also hörbuch ist es
irgendwie schief aus das ist schief
jetzt ist gerade oder es heute ganz nett
schief was ist schief das ding hat 16
euro kostet also eine sache sollte es
nicht sein und zwar schief ich muss mal
hier die krieg vorbereiten
[Musik]
ach da muss ich das noch für meine
familie ich habe für meine familie noch
neue karten machen lassen dies zeige ich
euch beim log den könnt ihr dann morgen
schauen
ich war dann nehme ich noch mehr eine
größere persönliche note reinpacken
deswegen verlose ich auch so viele von
denen die wir im stream gemacht haben
durch die arbeit bin ich immer noch
nicht in weihnachtsstimmung
aber man kann sich ja selbst auf der
arbeit meiner stimmung machen und das
ist alles auch ein bisschen so eine
frage der einstellung es klingt zu blöd
und ich weiß wenn man einen
anstrengenden job hat dann will man
eigentlich auch nicht hören dass man was
dran ändern können weil man sagt nein
mein job ist aber am ende muss
eigentlich jede arbeit spaß machen auch
wenn euch leute sagen wollen natürlich
deine arbeit muss spaß machen du musst
jahrelang hoppel ich arbeitete jahrelang
in irgendeinem beruf wenn du oder du
bist jemand der abwechslung braucht dann
arbeitswelt nicht so lange aber du
arbeitest jahre lang in einem beruf das
leben geht nicht darum irgend wie dein
soll dazu erfüllen irgendwie deine
stunden da abzusetzen und jeden tag nur
darauf zu hoffen dass du irgendwann mal
nach hause kommen kannst und irgendwie
die scheiße da also nee das und das ist
eine ein stimmt also
es ist heutzutage einfach nicht mehr so
dass das man so eingestellt sein sollte
es geht nicht nur darum irgendwie alles
gesellschaftlich gut zu erfüllen dass
man irgendwie ein paar spielt natürlich
muss nicht jeder irgendwie musiker
youtuber und schauspieler werden um
irgendwie seinen traum zu leben
aber man sollte etwas machen wo man
nicht und es kann ja auch zum beispiel
zum beruf im büro so der kampf weil die
eine person voll schön sein und für die
andere für scheiße aber meistens kommt
auch darauf an was für kollegen man hat
und wenn man schlechter kollegen hat und
sich irgendwie unwohl fühlt da wo man
arbeitet dann ist es eh schon also ich
akzeptiere nicht leute die jeden tag
nach hause kommen denken dass sie halt
am nächsten tag nicht mehr aufstehen
wollen und daher zur arbeit gehen wollen
sondern dass das ist so das ist nur lüge
dann kann man das sollte machen sich
nicht einreden dass das leben aus
besteht sich irgendwas zu irgendwas
durch zu quälen wenn du dein studium
nicht magst und das für dich eine
schlimme zeit ist und du irgendwie nur
unter stress bist und irgendwie nicht
kein kennt fröhlichen tag mehr
dann mach es nicht so nicht jeder muss
studieren
ich hatte nie vor zu studieren ich war
bin ja auch nicht ich hatte auch nie vor
youtuber oder entertainer als influenza
irgendwas zu sein team einfach mal das
gemacht was man ihr gesagt hat und wenn
es eine einzelhandelskauffrau ausbildung
war dann habe ich das gemacht aber ich
wusste dass irgendwie gefällt mir und
irgendwie hatte ich was und dann habe
ist es mir nicht mehr gefallen daran
habe ich damit aufgehört
sobald ich gemerkt habe dass mir nicht
gefällt ich habe nicht gesagt naja jetzt
habe ich hier schon drei monate
verbracht oder jetzt bin ich schon ein
jahr in dieser auswahl jetzt wäre blöd
abzubrechen das ist so schwachsinnig
solltest dich zwei jahre weiter quälen
weil du wenn du schon nach einem jahr
merkte es vorbei ist es wie bei einer
beziehung arbeitsbeziehung
liebesbeziehung ist als das gleiche wenn
du es nicht haben willst lass es gibt
keine begründung der welt sich um durch
irgendwas durch zu quälen was einem
keine freude bereitet was man nicht
machen möchte weil wenn du etwas tust wo
du keine freude daran hast du machst du
es schlechter als alle anderen und dann
bist du auch nicht weit genug gehen
es gibt kein orden für du hast gut
durchgehalten
sorry dass ich da so upgrade tv geht
einfach aus der kabine sein was begann
habe studiert ist abgebrochen und mache
jetzt in der ausbildung zur erzieherin
genau so und bist du glücklich ich hoffe
wir achten aber ich muss holz nachlegen
so dahin
holz ist nachgelegt
und
george fort
die drobs gehen an ihn
ich kann noch weiter abrutschen über
lebenseinstellungen viel aus solchen
haarschnitt haben wie du heißt manchmal
schwierig so ein pony ist wirklich ein
commitment
ja voll hat meine erste ausbildung nach
eineinhalb jahren abgebrochen weil ich
einfach latein behindert war
ich bin schwertkampf großmeister und
trainiere erwachsene und jugendliche ab
14 jahren und bin sehr glücklich das ist
auch mein beruf als hast du oft ein
youtube gezweifelt
nö ich habe nie daran gezweifelt
ich will jetzt gar nicht wie das so also
ich habe weder weil ich glaube also ich
glaube ich kann viele viele dinge ich
bin so zum beispiel super gut mit
kindern
ich habe bevor ich die schule mit der
schule fertig war habe ich schon viele
praktika im kindergarten gemacht
meine mutter war erzieherin ich habe
schon immer seit ich 14 bin als
babysitterin gearbeitet hatte ich hatte
immer familien habe ich im horten fsj
gemacht und in der grundschule und für
mich gehört das leben mit kindern
einfach immer dazu aber irgendwie habe
ich es dann nicht so beruflich gesehen
ich hatte dann ja ich hatte es da nicht
so aber fährt wenn youtube nicht klappt
ich glaube ich kann auch in irgendeiner
bar arbeiten
ich glaube irgendwie arbeiten und es
würde mich komplett glücklich machen so
tierpfleger im zoo das ist doch ob man
auch wenn es ja immer so aber ich glaube
tierpfleger als immer noch der beruf ist
ein besseren beruf kann man nicht haben
mit zu baby affen zu arbeiten
wenn justiz sekretärin hamburg und liebe
es justiz sigrid er was was macht man
denn dann ist wahrscheinlich so viel
papierkram für wen sie in die karten die
karten sind für die gewinner von der
verlosung die ich auf instagram gemacht
habe das sind weihnachtskarten ich kann
sie noch gerne zeigen für die diesen
mitgemacht team und ich am
weihnachtskarten gemacht im stream vor
paar tagen hier auf youtube
also die er dessen zuschauern gemacht
hab mein gott sie ist die nummer 31 die
die karten gemacht also die die das
motiv gemacht hat die kriegt auch ne
karte muss ich unbedingt daran denken
altenpflegerin in einer demenz station
da es auch absolut mein respekt ich
finde es sehr toll wenn menschen mit
alten und vor allem mit demenz umgehen
können
ich weiß nicht warum ich also ich hab
gemerkt wenn ich in der
behinderteneinrichtung in mein bruder
war oder darauf so stationen mit
behinderten umzugehen habe ich gar kein
also das ist für mich also ganz ganz
selbstverständlich und leicht aber mit
alten menschen fällt es mir aus
irgendeinem grund teil schwer
nicht weil ich sie nicht mag aber weil
ich da irgendwie ja ich war schlechtes
gewissen habe aber so ich war mir
irgendwie mehr leid tun und ich das ist
quatsch weil alle menschen haben auch
ein schönes leben und die müssen
eigentlich leid tun aber irgendwie ja
kann ich das nicht abstellen ok nächster
koks ist jetzt schon rotes wachs koks
ich gehe jetzt in die zehnte und ich
habe noch überhaupt keine ahnung was ich
nach der schule machen soll und das
solltest du auch nicht mein gott du
gehst in die zehnte du bist
wahrscheinlich 15
bitte glaubt nicht dass ihr mit 15 schon
verstanden haben müsst was ihr euer rest
des lebens machen wollt ich finde es so
komisch dass es in der schule
das ist aber unser ganzes schulsystem
ist so veraltet und es geht nicht darum
dass jeder einfach nur spaß haben
sondern sich selbst verwirklichen soll
das meine ich nicht aber es ist einfach
seltsam wie man in der schule dazu
gedrillt wird sogleich in so eine
schublade so du musst doch jetzt wissen
bist du wissenschaftler bist du
erzieherin was bist du
das einzige was man machen kann ist
immer wenn man sich für etwas
interessiert schon mal irgendwo
reinschnuppern richtige abwicklung hier
ok vor die sind so schön hausherr peter
jürgen hans guck mal das habe ich
gemacht ich bin so stolz auf mich ein
lernprozess hier
unsere lehrer dem demotivieren und bei
der jobsuche auch ganz ehrlich lehrer
sind wahrscheinlich selbst demotiviert
über ihre job entscheidung sagen
nimmt ein vw bus und fahren die welt
hinaus und wenn du dann irgendwann lust
hast kommst du zurück und macht etwas
gescheites
ich habe mit 16 entschieden frisörin zu
werden und habe es nie bereut
ja das ist mega wenn man schon mit 16
weiß wohin verschlägt dann dann brennt
man auch dafür nun gehört man da auch
definitiv in aber wenn man es mit 16
noch nicht weiß dann ist es halt auch
nicht schlimm ich finde das vergessen
einmal die erwachsenen zu sagen wenn man
in dem alter ist
ich habe dieses jahr ein praktikum bei
architekten gemacht wo architekt help
habe ich damals auch so gefeiert
das einzige was mich erschrocken hat war
wie gut man in mathe sein musste also
ich war irgendwie gut in mathe aber ich
war nicht fleißig genug weiß nicht ich
war immer nur fleißig wenn ich irgendwas
kreieren konnte also wenn am ende
irgendwas in meiner hand war oder
theaterstück oder so ein spielchen so ok
amadea die am radio darüber das ist wie
bleigießen
nur mit wachstum aber auch mittlerweile
wieder viel zu viel
[Musik]
leute wie geht's euch so aber einmal
könnte ich meine produktion eigentlich
war wenn ich nicht ob ich mal meine ring
man muss nur aufpassen dass man die
auszeit nicht zu lange macht nee das
stimmt man ja also die auszeit geht ja
nicht nur darum irgendwie zu versuchen
nicht arbeiten zu müssen später und wenn
man halt auch sich absolut nicht
vorstellen gerne klassisch zu arbeiten
da muss man halt auch an einfach einen
anderen weg finden geld zu verdienen so
es gibt wege geld verdienen so
klassische arbeit mit ausbildung beruf
links und dann halt in einen job rein
du kannst aber auch was eigenes staaten
du kannst ein startup gründen du kannst
du irgendeine richtung wo du glaubst du
kannst auch künstler werden also nichts
garantiert der halt ich glaube was
wonach wir suchen ist nach dieser
garantie
wir wollen diesen diesen job machen weil
wir dann irgendwie das gefühl haben dass
unsere zukunft garantiert ist dass wir
dieses gefühl von sicherheit für immer
spüren werden kannst du bei keinem job
ich hab' ich kenne jemand die hat bis
sie 31 bei jura studiert und dachte
immer dass die anwältin wird und dann
hat sie das jurastudium also also selbst
nicht geschafft und dann stand sie damit
30 zone muss das erstmal gucken und aus
ihr wurde auch was so
bin jetzt auch dank youtube am überlegen
ob ich heiteres arbeiten soll bereust du
irgendwas an youtube
ich will nicht zu viel sagen weil viele
sich ja auch immer sehr viele fühlen
sich immer sehr angegriffen wenn
youtuber sagen ich arbeite und ich
arbeite zu viel oder so ich weiß nicht
warum glaube die leute wollen immer noch
das gefühl haben dass youtube einfach
nur fun fun fun haben also die
selbstständigkeit ist teilweise sehr
anstrengend weil du halt sehr viel
arbeiten musst und sehr viel
selbstdisziplin brauchst also eigentlich
besteht dieser job opfers noch
selbstdisziplin weil es ja weil es immer
gleich kann es halt kein tag und
motiviert sein wenn du unmotiviert bist
machst du einen schlechten content oder
muss gar kein content und das bedeutet
dann du verdienst kein geld so ich kann
halt nicht schlecht also ja alles hatte
man gleich eine auswirkung du arbeitest
für niemanden habe ich nur für dich
selbst und das ist das ist ein segen
dass es wirklich ein segen für sich
selbst zu arbeiten weil das irgendwie
sich sehr natürlich anfühlt wie man halt
früher einfach für sich gearbeitet hat
indem man halt seinfeld geackert hat und
so dass es optisch kommt so fühlt sich
das auch ein bisschen an
aber es ist halt auch teilweise kann es
halt auch sehr an sehr anstrengend sein
weil
weil es niemanden gibt der dich dafür an
schnauzt dass du morgens im bett bleibt
und doch erst um 11 auf stehst
ich weiß manche träumen davon dass sie
lange ausschlafen können morgens aber in
der zeit in der ich einen regelmäßigen
beruf also job hatte wo ich irgendwie
früher irgendwo sein musste ja es hat
auch seine vorteile
das schließt nämlich jeden morgen auf
und weiß warum
weil du sonst auf die schnauze kriegs
von dem chef
ich betreue chronisch psychisch kranke
menschen um meine beste freundin auch
sein team ist super gemütlicher das
freut mich dass euch das gefällt oder
dem ein oder anderen ich hoffe die musik
könnt ihr ein bisschen hören und es
nicht störend wenn ihr gezwungen etwas
macht wird es nie was ja wenn man wenn
man den wunsch und den traum eines
anderen leben möchte oder seine eltern
oder nur seinen eltern gerecht werden
will
das ist absoluter quatsch
ihr seid keine kopie eure eltern oder
irgendwie die die ihre vorstellung im
leben weiter tragen müssen so ihr kommt
auf die welt ihr werdet von euren eltern
großgezogen damit ihr auch überlebt die
geben euch essen sie geben euch
sicherheit und liebe so das ist die
aufgabe deine eltern und danach stehst
du in der welt und wenn man ein baumhaus
leben möchtest dann ist das so dann hat
bist du niemandem irgendwie
rechtfertigung schuldig weil damit eure
eltern besitzen oder unsere eltern
besitzen uns ja nicht so meine eltern
waren auch nicht begeistert davon dass
sich youtube gemacht habe es war mehr zu
also zu keinem zeitpunkt habe ich das
als wichtig empfunden was sie über mein
leben denken so aber das ist halt mein
leben
wenn ich dann irgendwann im sterbebett
liege und mich darüber ärgere dass ich
das sind das nicht gemacht haben meine
eltern auch nicht da die sich irgendwie
das anhören dürfen dann sitze ich dann
nämlich alleine und ärger mich einfach
nur darum was ich für lebens
entscheidung getroffen habe
ich bin zwölf weiß auch nicht genau was
ich machen weil ich da ich hab das
gefühl es gibt so viele berufe so dass
man ja gar nicht entscheiden kann
also was man immer machen kann bevor man
sich in irgendeiner ausbildung stürzt
gibt euch ein jahr zeit und schaut euch
berufe an wirklich auch so sachen wo man
erst mal andenkt kann mir nicht
vorstellen
manche berufe sind überraschenderweise
total toll und manche berufe wo man
dachte das ist ein super toller beruf
kann sich als supervisor herausstellen
einfach ausprobieren praktika machen
noch mehr praktika machen und irgendwann
wenn man es weiß da macht man es
und nicht irgendwelche studien also im
studium anfang nur weil man möchte dass
die eltern irgendwie ruhe geben oder
weil man denkt dass man jetzt studieren
muss ich sag euch wisst ihr was man als
was man später viel geld verdienen wird
als handwerker und wisst ihr warum also
vielleicht nicht was reparieren weil die
leute werden immer mehr wegschmeißen
weil alle leute gehen in die medien alle
leute wollen was mit medien machen und
handwerker werden immer seltener und die
verdienen aber auch gut weil sie müssen
bezahlt werden
also angebot und nachfrage man nicht
damit
das verhältnis zwischen mir und meinen
eltern doch das ist in ordnung ja ich
würde sagen es ist es hat so die in
einen oder anderen faktoren die man
verbessern könnte
aber das wichtigste ist sich immer als
individuum zu sehen und nicht
also was ich früher mal nämlich gemacht
habe ist viel viel meinen eltern die
schuld für etwas gegeben aber nicht so
böswillig und so du bist schuld dass ich
nicht aber man wusste ich immer ja das
kann ich nicht so gut oder damit kann
ich nicht so umgehen weil meine eltern
aber ich also ich habe gelernt auch
gerade dieses hörbuch was ich gehört
habe dass mir ganz klar und begründet
ist mir ganz klar gewonnen das so
nee ich bin jetzt ich bin jetzt raus von
zu hause und ich trage die verantwortung
für mein leben und ich kann mich
entscheiden glücklich zu sein aber ich
kann mich auch entscheiden in meinem
unglück rom zu baden und zu sagen nee
ich kann ja jetzt gar nicht glücklich
sein weil das und das und das und ich
habe ja ein super keine ahnung dass und
das ist ja gerade nicht perfekt ich kann
jetzt gerade gar nicht möglich sein und
dieses herr borat wirklich in manchen
punkten mich richtig ja nicht richtig
verändert und so umgekehrt und ja ich
bin einfach ich will ein zufriedener
mensch und ich weiß es solange ich mich
nicht aufgibt wird alles gut aber es ist
nicht so dass meine eltern mich jetzt
aufgegeben haben oder so also ist alles
in ordnung mit managern ist halt auch
einfach schwieriger mit der ganzen
geschichte mit meinem bruder und so was
alles damit passiert ist wir hatten halt
andere challenges und andere sachen mit
dem wir umgehen mussten aber ich glaube
dafür habe es ganz gut hingekriegt
hast du mal erfahrungen mit alkoholikern
gemacht ja in meiner familie gibt es
alkoholiker tatsächlich ich dachte auch
immer das warum ich bin dort können wir
haben schon immer viel getrunken aber
ich habe also definitiv zurück also ich
bin ich trinke ich trinke jetzt seltener
und nicht mehr so ausfallend also ich
achte schon darauf
möchtest du mal zu einem auftritt von
gemischtes hackfleisch den super gerne
ich würde auch so gerne mit dem felix
und tommy marin oder einfach mal nur mit
denen ein bier trinken so mit dem felix
ruprecht in berlin schon bier trinken
das einfach mal reden
ich passte gerade ein 3d origami schwarm
an dem ich schon fünf tage arbeit und
ein ziel dabei ist sehr entspannt hammer
3d origami
es ist so eine coole vorstellung dass er
da gerade an eurem pc oder an einem
laptop oder handy sitzt und auch
irgendwie gerade was macht ich weiß auch
nicht ob das für alle streamer so ich
kann da nicht bei anderen youtube an
oder ist wie man so einblicke nicht weiß
ich wie sie ticken aber ich habe das
gefühl wenn wir also wenn ich leicht bin
und wir so miteinander kommunizieren ich
fühle mich richtig so ich bin nicht blöd
klingen was fühlt sich irgendwie weniger
allein sondern halt jetzt so zusammen
alle und wir machen jetzt alle zusammen
was sonst würde ich halt sitzen und kein
wort sagen so eigentlich mit euch
unterhalten könnten nur schwer antworten
aber ich bin sowieso so selbstverliebte
und egoistisch dass ihr handy nur ihn
möchte
komm wir machen weihnachtsmusik an bis
in bock habe ich schon wieder
kriegt jetzt auch genau das
ihr kommt jetzt ich zwinge euch jetzt
kommt jetzt in weihnachtsstimmung
wir haben nur noch fünf tage dann ist
heiligabend in stimmung bringen
[Musik]
ich habe keine lust mehr auf schule so
lange man lesen und schreiben kann es
doch alles gut in paar jahren wird er
alles von technik gesteuert also schule
ist zwar nervig aber in der schule lernt
man viele sachen und dein gehirn vor
allem in der schulzeit brauch ich habe
mal mit den lehrern ganz lange darüber
gesprochen weil ich auch meine so hat
man braucht doch keine chemie und man
braucht kein mathe und hat gesagt mir
braucht man nicht aber was das gehirn
braucht ist gerade während der kindheit
und der schulzeit das ist neue sachen
lernt ist natürlich schade dass man so
viele sachen lernt muss auf die man
durch kein bock hat weil man könnte ja
auch den unterricht anpassen und jemand
der geschichte interessiert ist kann ja
viel über geschichte lernen aber weniger
über chemie aber du brauchst du dass
dein hirn jeden tag beansprucht wird
weil da werden neue synapsen knospen
da wird halt einmal alles verbunden es
entwickelt sich das ist ein muss wie ein
muskel trainiert wenn du jeden tag nahm
orie spielen würdest würdest auch halt
irgendwann richtig gut in der mobi
werden für mein gott ich habe gewonnen
ich zeichne nebenbei auf dem ipad was du
nicht siehst du inspiriert mich sehr zum
zeichnen aber das finde ich schön
[Musik]
also wenn ihr auch probleme mit anxiety
und stress und so habt und noch nie mal
ausprobiert hat euch irgendwie also ich
glaube das ist künstlerisch also malen
basteln mäßig für jeden etwas gibt eine
freundin zu mir von demnach zum beispiel
makramee das ist somit so schnürchen so
schwierig nicht mit seien so sachen
knoten also so band den konsum und sie
war jetzt auch nie die die größte
künstlerin aber jeder braucht so ein
handwerk um einfach abzuschalten wenn
ihr noch nichts gefunden habt dann such
mal was
spirit of christmas i do chemie
ausspricht chemie
ich sage schon das sage ich auch mal ich
sag mal auf sanierten servietten mehr
servierten sag ich immer die leute regen
sich auch mal mega über servierten auch
für mich lindes servietten und das wird
sich hier nichts dann risse brüssel
wollt ihr irgendwann mal kinder des
netto h lief auf die frage wie jetzt
nicht mehr gerechnet
kinder ja das ist so eine typische
antwort jetzt erstmal nicht
ich habe also geht natürlich denkt man
über kinder nachher warum sollte man
wird was für mich irgendwie ganz klar
ist dass ich glaub ich später auf jeden
fall pflegekinder haben werde
vielen die nicht das erzähle die sagen
dann ja aber also das schön natürlich
auch sehr ehrenhaft ihren frau aber das
ist ja das kann ja schwere schwierige
kinder sein und die können ja was
durchgemacht haben und genau deswegen
möchte ich das heißt weil
ich ja es ist schön so seine eigene
gehen weiter zu denken oder an einem
eigenen kind kann glaube ich nichts
vergleichen
aber wenn ich mir vorstelle dass sich
ein kind ein zuhause geben kann das kein
schönes zuhause hatte und irgendwie
meine weihnachts sucht und kindlichkeit
und weihnachtsbäckerei so weitergehen
kann und dadurch irgendwie jemanden
schönes eine schöne kinder schenken kann
ich glaube ich glaube das macht einen
selbst auch glücklich einfach und ich
bin youtube-star leute ich verdient so
viel geld ich kann 30 kinder aber auch
viel berichtet manchmal ich könnte mir
den stream auch nicht ich kann dir gerne
online lassen aber ich könnte mir den
stream danach nicht anschauen
ich sehe was ich für eine scheiße aber
das hörbuch hieß es denn die antenne und
auf englisch deine seele befreit sein
ich muss aber auch sagen dass englische
rufen ich am besten
ich würde es nicht lesen wollen weil
gesprochen gibt es einen so kriegt es
ein so richtig denkt man so jammern
wurden die gewinner schon erwähnt die
gewinner
die habe ich schon gezeigt vor 3 stunden
also ich hoffe dass noch keiner hier
drei stunden dabei ist das gefühl dass
ich heute zeitraum wird die bewohner
lieben es ich verabschiede mich heute
abend dankeschön dc bis bald
[Musik]
mir hilft es immer meine gefühle als
lyrix aufzuschreiben und dann mit der
gitarre passende dienste spielen einfach
mit 20 ja das finde ich auch das ist
auch so künstlerisch sich ausdrücken
ich fühle mich eigentlich nicht mit 25
aber alle um mich herum raten bekommen
gerade kinder da fühlt man sich komisch
ist es bei dir auch so mein gott ja du
sprichst mir wirklich aus der seele
du sprichst mir aus der seele weil ich
komme ja auch aus dem dorf und dort wo
ich herkomme die ganzen mädels sind
gerade alle am kinderkriegen und
heiraten und ich sitze hier in berlin
ist rime wie ich weihnachtspost an meine
zuschauer wären die gerade irgendwie
windelnwechseln wahrscheinlich
[Musik]
also ich finde ich weiß nicht ist sich
mit komischen meistens sind aber auch
die wirklich die mädels die in der
heimat geblieben sind also im dorf
aufgewachsen sondern nicht stadt zieht
die leute die auf dem dorf geblieben
sind die wollen das aber auch die
zelebrieren dieses haus kind hund und
man so und dann wisst ihr was ich meine
was ja auch super ich meinen
nicht jede macht das im crazy stadt
leben glücklich aber deswegen vergleicht
man also man sollte sich nicht mit
leuten vergleichen wenn sie zum beispiel
dass alle kinder kriegen und heiraten
wenn man genau so tickt wie die also man
sollte menschen diese schublade packen
aber es gibt ja schon so grobe
schubladen arten von menschen und wenn
du jetzt denkst dass du wie die anderen
mädels eigentlich auch so bist dann
arbeite an einem ziel zu heiraten und
kinder zu kriegen
das kann man alles erreichen
sie liegt mir ganz verschieden sein
aber wenn du nicht so text wie die leute
die gerade kinder kriegen und so dann
mach dir im stress ist es einfach nicht
dein weg
ich dachte ich könnte den stream jetzt
da beide schon wo ich eben aufgehört
hatte und jetzt spielst du immer noch ja
immer noch das sehen wir die life ball
schön aus schwer sei dass es harry
potter brief einfach in der einladung
nach hogwarts
denn seit sogar eine stunde 30 dabei
würde grüßt mich vanessa bitte komm
schon benjamin ich grüße dich ja und
nicht jeden machen kinder glücklich und
wisst ihr was mir letztens aufgefallen
ist so zum thema kinderkriegen sonne
wisst ihr was das und nachhaltigste ist
was man machen können kinder kriegen
wenn du so einen menschen in die welt
setzt der verbraucht wasser der
verbraucht sauerstoff
jetzt denkt man die ganzen öko familien
mit ihren kindern so öko sind die nicht
[Musik]
wollte sich keinen stress machen
früher war das irgendwie noch schlimmer
wir haben ja noch glück heutzutage wir
können ja sagen wir wollen keine kinder
wenn du das tor in den fünfzigern gesagt
hast dann warst du schon rührt wenn du
keine kinder haben wollte
wir haben schon nicht mehr freiheiten
du hast mich jetzt du hast mich gerade
dazu gebracht dass mein bett
aufzusteigen muss produktives zu machen
macht produktive sachen leute ihr habt
nur dieses eine leben und ihr solltet es
mit wachs und einer kerze und briefen an
zuschauern verbringen
circa zwar schon war zwischendurch ein
kauf so wird sich die forschung dass ihr
da jetzt wirklich sitzt also ich weiß es
ja aber wenn man sich das mal sind so
viele leben also ihr alle
ich kann das mir ganz mit mir gar nicht
vorstellen wie viele lebensgeschichten
so ich habe das super interessant
und ich bin in jedem dankbar der seine
zeit für mich opfert wirklich könnt ihr
euch die glauben 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 stück
lulus kitchen ist schon ganz sauer weil
ich sie noch nie gegrüßt habe hier ist
der gruß hallo liebe grüße des ticino
sketchen ich grüße dich ganz herzlich
danke dass ich hier heute abend dabei
bist ich freue mich so julius kitchen
dankeschön
was denkst du über die lgbt community
alle raus ja nein spaß
also ich finde das ist ja eine tolle
community ich weiß ich kann man kann man
sie schlecht sind kann man irgendwie
kritik an der lgbt community haben wir
würden nichts einfallen also die sind
viel zu positiv ich mag es nicht wenn
menschen positiv sind und ging sich
untereinander unterstützen und und nett
sind und das was ich meine
die lgbt community ist das beste also
auch dieses diese offener dieses
untereinander und sich unterstützen das
beste was unsere gesellschaft passieren
konnte tatsächlich
neben sich das mal vorstellen wie viel
wie viele autos wie viele diskussionen
oder einfach wie oft das thema jetzt in
den letzten drei jahren aufgetaucht ist
ich weiß nicht
ja es ist einfach ja es gibt nichts
negatives sagen wird oder keine ahnung
ich finde es eher gesagt jeder der noch
irgendwie ein problem hat mit schwulen
lesben trans irgendwas was anders ist
als man frau und miteinander
jeder der irgendwie da ein problem hat
hat kein problem mit sich selbst sage
ich ganz ehrlich
also was ich so mitbekomme ist immer das
sind arme schweine ist die irgendwie
stress machen wollen
timo ist also wie geht es dem us-kino
ist zudem kumpel gefahren mit dem jetzt
pa spielt ich muss so süß er liebt seine
neue brille und das ist wirklich zucker
ist lebensfreude dass dieser junge timo
das pure lebensfreude ich glaube von ihm
habe ich auch ein bisschen abgeguckt
ich habe früher mal gedacht ist man auch
so dass man auch ich weiß ich hab immer
gedacht dass man auch nicht so glücklich
sein soll oder nicht übertreiben sollte
mit seinem glück mit genießen lecker
essen einfach das leben genießen und
dann habe ich so kino kennen gelernt und
hab gedacht so junge immer auf so ganz
zeit glücklich zu sein und zufrieden mit
dem was du hast dann habe ich mir das
abgeguckt wird wie auf dauer glücklich
ich bin lesbisch meiner eltern
akzeptieren es nicht
so zieht versuche kommen juristischen
therapie machen um mich ranzulassen
achso mir so leid ich finde das so
schlimm
dass sie was eltern nicht verstehen die
glauben die mission sich zu sehr
die benutzten ihre kinder um sich selbst
zu identifizieren wisst ihr was ich
meine sie können nicht ihre kinder als
einzelnen menschen ansehen sondern die
sind so verworren in diesen verlorenen
verworrener
wie wirst du sie meinen verbogen und
diesem konstrukt das dass die kinder sie
selbst wieder spielen das einfach nicht
stimmt so die eltern nehmen sich halt
einfach viel zu wichtig dass er sich
bewegen
wieso gerade ich sitze ich hier bestimmt
schon eine stunde vor dem fernseher
dynasty habe währenddessen
vanessa hat gerade gecheckt dass hier
menschen zuschauen die wirklich leben
können ja jetzt alle ein leben eine
geschichte ich bin verwirrt
mal eine frage wenn du kinder haben
wirst das sowie teilweise öffentlich
machen ist eine gute frage
also ich bin ernten durch ich verstehe
die contra leute also ich versteh
menschen die sagen das kind hat eigene
rechte und sollte nicht also solange es
nicht entscheiden kann
blablabla wir auch noch eigene theorie
ich glaube nicht also ich hätte kein
problem wenn ich jetzt so also gehen wir
halt vom schlimmsten aus und dann wären
sie gemobbt dafür dass die eltern sich
schon als kind und so das kann natürlich
passieren aber das ist halt auch
unwahrscheinlich und viele kinder müssen
mit viel schlimmere sachen umgehen
wirklich viele kinder haben alkoholiker
eltern allgemein drogenabhängige eltern
eltern die sich nicht richtig um ihre
kinder kümmern können eltern die ihn
niemals hätten eltern werden sollen und
sich schlecht um ihre kinder kümmern
und da finde ich so eltern die in der
öffentlichkeit stehen und dadurch die
kinder auch wenn ich das kleinste
problem
und wenn die kinder sich später
entscheiden und sagen ich habe keine
lust auf dieses öffentlichkeit wenn dann
werden sie das irgendwann sagen sobald
sie es verstehen und dann lässt man sie
auch aber ich sehe nicht so ganz das
leid was man den kindern zuträgt es ist
am ende ja auch der job von also sehr
babys job in der öffentlichkeit zu
stehen und das kind wird so viele
vorteile dadurch haben dass die
finanziell so abgesichert sind
das kind kann so viele sich träume
wahrscheinlich verwirklichen wenn es
nicht verzogen wird und einfach nur mit
geld überschüttet wird dann ist
natürlich auch wieder schlecht aber das
kind wird von so vielen also wird so
viel machen können dadurch dass die
eltern finanziell so einfach baby und
julian sind so common alter der wird
alles was der dann wird vieles nicht
struggle müssen was andere struggle
und da kann man es also bisher
da gehört dann einfach auch dazu dass na
ja gut dann musste er oder stand erhält
in der kindheit vor der kamera ich weiß
nicht das zu verurteilen
deshalb weil baby und julian bestimmt
auch tolle eltern sind so das können wir
nicht entscheiden
[Musik]
die hacker konnten sich genommen hat
auch nicht aussuchen wisst ihr ich sage
euch 2030 geht es dann darum wann geben
wir kinder nahmen wenn sie akzeptieren
können dass sie die kinder haben viel
mehr zu leiden gehabt weil sie irgendwie
ein stück zeitnah verlieren ändern
bekommen haben und wurden die ganze zeit
gehänselt so wird es irgendwann das
nächste sein dass eltern die
entscheidung für den namen weggenommen
wird
ich finde eltern sollten sich halt
irgendwann mal zurückziehen wenn kinder
alt genug sind sorgen
meine mutter hat mich vorhin als
emotional instabil betitelt und hat mir
gedroht und auch passiert sind davon war
ich angefangen zu wenn sie nicht neben
schule an
also
eltern sind die wichtigsten menschen im
leben
aber nicht die einzigen so das ist meine
meinung zu ändern
habe gehört ja es gibt eltern die sich
für die psyche ihrer kinder schämen weil
wie gesagt sie ist es nicht
unterscheiden können
für manche eltern sind ihre kinder wie
wie ein statussymbol
oder wieso ein produkt wofür sie
verantwortlich sind wenn dieses produkt
nicht den vorstellungen oder perfekt ist
und so wie man es sich also
schwiegersohns liebling schwiegertochter
schwiegermamas liebling so dann fühlen
sie sich als ob sie versagt hätten
oder wenn das kind sich nur schwarz
anziehen möchte und zu death metal bands
wer sich das gar nicht vorstellen allein
müssen wir einfach geld haben keine
ahnung haben
es sind so viele briefe ich können
sterben aus paraguay wow kann sogar ein
bisschen vitamin d3 rüber schicken ich
muss es jetzt supplement ihren der
hogwarts wird hier die briefe bald
verteilen
ich bin seit der ersten stunde dabei
müsste eigentlich konzentriert hat mit
der masterarbeit wird es schreibt einem
master weiß ich will nicht dafür
verantwortlich sein dass du es nicht
schaffst
[Musik]
ich glaube das wichtigste ist das thema
eltern ist beschäftigt viele oder das
ist aber auch was wofür also man liest
zwar oft in kommentaren und so dass über
probleme die man zu hause da war es ist
so unfair dass man mit zu vielen mit so
vielen sachen zu kämpfen hat und oft
wirklich das gefühl hat dass da draußen
niemand ist den das interessiert oder
der der ein helfen kann
unser kinderarzt hat sich letztens bei
meinem mann ausgelassen war eine mutter
wissen wollte ob sie ihr kind mit
pusteln in die kita schicken kann
wenn das ständig enttäuscht und traurig
weil es mir nicht gut geht aber was soll
ich da machen
das erste was man glaube ich wenn es
einem nicht gut geht und man depressiv
ist oder sich depressiv fühlt das
wichtigste ist dass man sich ganz
bewusst darüber ist dass man da wieder
rauskommen kann
das ist keine sackgasse des aber es
fühlt sich immer wie eine sackgasse an
wenn es dir schlecht geht als ich die
panikattacke hat es hat sich angefühlt
wie so okay das ist jetzt mein leben ich
werde nicht mehr rausgehen können man
kann sich nicht vorstellen dass es sich
wieder bessern kann aber diese hoffnung
oder diesem glauben daran dass alles
wieder besser werden kann darf man nicht
verlieren und das ist das wichtigste ist
auch so eine floskel jemand oft hört ja
es wird doch wieder so keine sorge
irgendwann wird es wieder gut
aber das ist schon es schon ernst
gemeint ist
oh ja
mein bruder ruft die ganze zeit
eigentlich hätten ihn an kann ich so
nachricht ich kann gerade nicht sprechen
also in das wachs in die kerze gefallen
leute ihr sein kann ihn ja auch einfach
das so
der mangel an therapieplätzen macht es
nicht besser ja und ich glaube aber auch
dass alternative therapien sowie hypnose
zum beispiel davon halten viele nicht
also kann er verstehen dass viele das
komisch finde so sind hilft so aber es
gibt so viele alternative heilmethoden
schönemann also während ich meine
panikattacken zu kämpfen gehabt habe
hatten wir die psychische therapie also
verhaltenstherapie auch geholfen aber
ich weiß nicht ich habe mich bei den
anderen therapeuten die eine zum
beispiel die hypnosetherapie gemacht hat
ich habe mich irgendwie besser
verstanden gefühlt und schneller geheilt
natürlich ist alles arbeit und dauert
zeit aber es gibt halt auch für viele
probleme eine schnelle lösung aber daran
weiß ich nicht das ist halt
wenn man es von der krankheit alles
zahlen lassen muss es dann macht es das
halt ma bis zu 100 watt komplizierter
wisst ihr
hast du dir ein eigenes siegel ich habe
bestehen das motiv genommen es gab nicht
so viele motive aber ich habe eins
gefunden
mit so einem wie heißt das ich weiß ich
wie das heißt
david s
da sieht es perfekt ein eigenes siegel
wäre natürlich super gewesen aber dann
hätte es wahrscheinlich noch mehr
gekostet hat 16 euro
auf einer skala von eins bis zehn wie
stark ist deshalb noch ich habe noch
überlegt ob ich darüber ein video machen
soll
also was heißt main pts halb obwohl ja
ich also ich höre die musik seltener
ich schaue mir nicht mehr so viele
youtube videos von denen an ich würde
sagen meine pts hat sich echt minimiert
aber ich liebe sie immer noch aber nicht
mehr so intensiv stimmt eigentlich das
ist kompliziert meine beziehung zu ihm
eine linie ist es eine renaissance
schnörkel dingen keine ahnung wie das
beschreiben soll so recht also ich sehe
es als renaissance schnörkel ding und
ich glaube dass auch die offizielle
bezeichnung davon
oh mein gott ist das schön
und dann muss ich noch 40 für meine
familie machen
warum ist dann weiter oder wollt ihr
nicht schluss machen
ich habe gerade überlegt wie lange wir
noch streamen können aber irgendwann das
dann auch mal gut
hast du schon mal getroffen ich habe
schon vor vier jahren getroffen oder so
vor fünf wochen noch ganz klein
er kann sie noch keiner ja ok kamera war
doch nicht dann zurück ich liebe deine
einstellung du wirkst wie eine sehr
ausgeglichen
dankeschön wisst ihr was ich schön
gefühl habt ja ich wirklich glaube ich
wirklich mittlerweile wieder wie eine
wii version x ausgeglichene person und
ich finde so eine aussage negativ sie
aber die panikattacken zeit und die
depressive zeit die wo es mir super
schlecht gehen
das war eine zeit in der ich so
unglaublich viel gelernt habe dass ich
das nicht umtauschen möchte
es musste genauso passieren und meinen
weg musste genau so holprig sein dass
ich jetzt einfach so geworden bin wie
ich mich auch gerne am liebsten glaube
ich mag leute der letzte der muss
perfekt werden
der ist perfekt geworden oder
in essen
bitte grüßt benny bitte bitte bitte cruz
beni ok benny film ist film ist benny
benny bereit okay liebe grüße an dich
benny lässt so den stream online ja ich
glaube ich dass in stream online
weitermachen es ist schön zu wissen es
nicht
timo timo hat mir während meiner zeit
also wir kennen uns ich kann euch mal
verraten weil wir unter uns können
darüber reden und ich sind schon seit
fast drei jahren zusammen so viele leute
haben die glückwunsch und so gegeben und
das fand ich total schön aber wenn man
mit ihm schon fast drei jahre zusammen
ist dann ist es so ja also danke wir
sind schuld dieser glück glücks blicks
phase vorbei also glücklich aber wir
sind nicht mehr in dieser verliebte
phase denkt an die 31 karte ganz gut
doch noch nicht ihr habt gedacht der
stream mit buy aber der ist noch nicht
vorbei denn jetzt kommt noch 31 kassel
und ihr fragt euch was ist die eine
adresse karte
die ist nämlich für
die sie noch mal auf ins tal
die latte
die latte der ehemalige profi ja
diese feine dame hat die karten
gestaltet und die kriegt natürlich jetzt
auch ein
berlin
ich weiß es zb für alle die jetzt noch
mal nicht gewonnen haben aber
liebe karin liebe
[Musik]
ich danke
dieses
tolle
[Musik]
ak
im nachhinein zieht doch niemand drei
stunden es endlich klappt halt auch
nicht oder
also so life school bei ihr könnt mir
schreiben und ich kann darauf antworten
so leistung hat aber im nachhinein
ich bin schon seit drei stunden dauern
die zeit vergeht und probiert ich finde
auch operativ volk wirklich willst du
deine nachrichten instagram also viele
aber ich hab nicht alle ich ärger mich
immer wenn ich dann die nachlese die
total schöne sondern habe ich irgendwie
erst drei wochen später einmal so kurz
aber ihr müsst mir da auch nicht böse
sein weil das ist so perfekt geworden
ein richtiger profi mittlerweile darin
wenn ich mir die ersten anschauen
obwohl die heftigen haben halt auch
ihren charme eine person die diese karte
kriegen wird weiß einfach dass ist
prozess war aber ich weiß nicht mehr ob
die personen jettes danke für die idee
dass so wie bleigießen zu machen
ich weiß dass kurz markieren des kamins
cham
nach ihm kam
eine wild card gewinnerin
meine so schön dass du ganz offen über
alles sprichst
ich weiß nicht
[Musik]
also ich ja ich habe euch einfach alles
offen aber ich glaube auch weil ich
ich weiß nicht ich möchte jetzt nicht
warum ich offen sprechen sollte so jetzt
wo ich ja die sache mit timo endlich
veröffentlicht habe fühle ich mich
richtig so
jetzt kann ich euch alles sagen so und
jetzt jetzt ist so jetzt hab ich habe
keine geheimnisse voreinander mehr alle
außer drei kriegen deine dna ja
tatsächlich schon wenn ihr mich clown
wollt
dann schickt die person danach also die
geklonte person bitte zu mir und sie
soll für mich arbeiten
ich bräuchte noch so eine zweite vanessa
dann würde alles super funktioniert mit
youtube ich bin aber so aufgeregt ich
habe heute wirklich so ein büro
angeguckt
mein gott es ist so schön und es hat so
eine perfekte lage und da sind nette
leute und dass wir einfach so super ich
habe das heute ein geguckt und dachte
mir so ja als das universum hat schon
wieder mit mir gesprochen weil ich auf
dem weg dahin habe ich so karl
also kein taxi sondern diese anderen
arten von carsharing dieses fahrdienst
in anspruch genommen und dann hab ich
gerade seo auf dem weg gehört sie sagt
ich würde auf jeden fall hat er gerade
etwas pietro lombardi blablabla gesagt
und habe ich so hoch geguckt und war
damit fast so wie pietro lombardi saturn
werbung ganz groß war nicht so mein gott
das universum spricht wieder mit mir
werden die gewinner der karten noch
unter dein instagram post markiert ich
schreibe die gewinner der karten jetzt
gleich an
also ich bin jetzt fertig mit denen in
dem hier und ich schreibe dir gleich
alle an ich habe schon von einigen die
adressen bekommen weil ich ein paar
schon angeschrieben habe aber ich
schreibe jetzt den rest noch an
und wenn ihr heute noch eine nachricht
bekommt dann wisst ihr ob ihr gewonnen
habt also in der nächsten halben stunde
ich hoffe ich kriege ja ich habe die
seite nicht geschlossen habe ich nicht
mehr wo alles so mies nicht das sind die
gewinner
mein gott wie scheifele das gewesen was
aber sehr bunt gemischt also zwischen
mann und frau
viele männer für die frauen hat auch
mehr frauen ist ja auch mein wissen wie
sehen die grundierung ich ein paar
prozent habe ich ein bisschen mehr
frauen als männer
ich bin rechts an ich bin nicht links
dann darf ich habe nur ganz eng mit
links aufs festgehalten weil ich nicht
so machen wollte okay leute
also ich hoffe euch geht's gut
wir sehen uns entweder morgen abend am
morgen gleich video hoch dann sehen wir
uns vor weihnachten gar nicht mehr so
face to face fenster sowie mögen sich
ziehen könnte ja man hat das universum
spricht mit mir aber nicht auf sondern
werde um die wird verrückt art sondern
das universum
es kommen immer viel zu viele zufälle
also ich erlebe immer viel zu viele
zufälle wie gemütlich main stream aus
eigentlich hätte gern sind so machen
müssen wer irgendwie optisch besser
gewesen aber main stream sieht sehr
gemütlich aus kommt man diese kerze und
und dürfen weitermachen soll ich
wahnsinnig soll ich echt weitermachen
gutes 20 36 muss er noch weiterarbeiten
ja ich herkomme müssen auch irgendwann
schluss machen
also muss man nicht schluss machen wenn
es am schönsten ist
nee ich ganz ehrlich ich halte euch nur
aufwändig stream ich möchte jetzt dass
ihr euch direkt ins gesicht
ich möchte dass ihr jetzt den stream
ausmacht leid nicht mehr so viel social
media macht außerdem ist noch gucken ob
ich auch unseren aber sonst nicht mehr
so wie social media macht und schaut
nach vielleicht macht ihr euch ein harry
potter herr buchan mein größter traum in
weihnachtsstimmung zu kommen
harry potter herr buchan machen oder
herr der ringe schauen aber beim harry
potter herr buch könnt ihr euch noch
irgendwie möglich irgendwie was neuen
und ihr könnt kreativ sein und bitte
sagt nicht weiter machen wenn ihr weiter
sagt das ist so viel mehr ich schlafen
tue ich jetzt ähnlich ich muss ich muss
jetzt hier also dass hier muss ich jetzt
auch noch mit denen karten für meine
familie machen das heißt an sich können
wir hier genauso weiter sitzen und das
gleiche machen aber weiter
wir machen heute noch die fünf stunden
voll
aber ich werde ja ich mache weiter
ich hasse das sprechen also dass eure
antworten später kommen als mein
sprechen das was meine
nein ich muss
ich weiß jetzt zwingt mich nicht an ich
weiß ich kann auf wenn ich will aber ich
bin auch ich will eigentlich auch weiter
machen aber dann bin ich so hin und
hergerissen ich sag mal so ich mache
weiter
ich gehe aber nun kannst gleich jetzt
kurz auf toilette muss meine kopfhörer
absetzen
alles vor unangenehm so lange gekocht
jahre darauf sagen ich mach jetzt kurz
wie ein kleines geschäft bei
überweisungen okay sind wir ja sind die
unter macht euch mal auch ein stück
essen weil sie nicht nur ein blatt
papier zeichnet was
ich will euch nicht wir sehen uns in
zehn minuten wieder nennen
[Musik]
gemütlicher stream ag
kommt
[Musik]
in
in war
[Musik]
zahlen
zum morgengrauen
[Musik]
geht's los
tür zu
[Musik]
krismer
kommt
[Musik]
okay mir ist was eingefallen der garde
ich muss ja diesen prozess von den
anderen was ich im film für den block
weil sonst mich brauchst du in den
bunten frack mich auch nicht mehr das
tri möchte aber dann wieder streep
[Musik]
ist ein bisschen schwierig
auch wenn
[Musik]
deswegen
haben wir natürlich passen
[Musik]
die musik so las ich habe schon gesagt
dass wir die musik ist zu alt gute kunst
musik
seit man selber kreativ macht was und
wenn ihren harten arbeitstag habt dann
entspannt euch schön könnt euch die
freizeit und ich wünsche euch morgen
allen einen guten start in den tag ist
morgen freitag wird noch ein paar tage
bis weihnachten wahrscheinlich habt ihr
dann auch alle frei ab morgen mittag
oder abend je nachdem was hier arbeiten
müsst und wenn ihr an weihnachten
arbeiten müsste dann tut es mir sehr
sehr leid ich hoffe euch jetzt gut
hier geht es gut ist gesund und wenn
nicht dann wünsche ich euch gute
besserung und alles wird gut das ist ein
motto für heute abend
ok
si
pünktlich zum arbeitsbeginn hörst du auf
ich muss jetzt ruhig arbeitet auch weil
er quasi ich mache ich die blogging
kameramann und dann geht's ab ok gute
gute vibes only und bis bald